[Music]
[Music]
so
this universe is made of light
and darkness
these ancient forces flow through all
matter and energy
in our solar system
and beyond
but we haven't always known this
when the traveler
arrived in our solar system
they called it many things
a ship
a planet
a god
its presence provoked and inspired great
change
it terraformed several moons and planets
our lifespans increased threefold
and we launched colony ships to settle
worlds beyond our own
this was our golden age
but like all golden ages
it was doomed to collapse
the traveler was pursued by an ancient
enemy
a voice
in the darkness
it found us
humanity lost everything
with the last of its strength
the traveler pushed back its enemy
to create something new
the ghosts
in the dark times that followed the
collapse
the ghosts chose the first light bearers
immortal warriors gifted with the power
of the traveler's light
humanity faced many threats in those
days
invaders from beyond our system arrived
in droves
pirates called the fallen came to
scavenge the remains of our golden age
the war like cabal
came for our territory and resources
for conquest
the hive
ravenous worshipers of death
came to feed their infernal hunger
and the vex
strange living machines
came to recreate our world in their own
brutal image
we fought with each other
as well
for a time
chaos reigned
though in the end
we came together
to rebuild
to heal
we built a city under the traveler
the last safe city of earth
in this city
humanity lived peacefully in all its
forms
[Music]
the humans
earth's original inhabitants
the exos marvels of the golden age
and the awoken
a people touched by both light
and dark
light bearers took an oath to protect
the last city
over the centuries
they earned the title
guardians guardians
[Music]
the titans
paragons of strength and bravery
the warlocks
mage scholars trained in the arcane arts
and the hunters
bold adventurers gifted with cunning
guardians know that when they stand
together
they are stronger
and now
new threats use our own powers against
us
the black fleet closes in
edging us toward a second collapse
and our greatest adversary
the voice in the darkness
is revealed
a being of unimaginable power
the witness
but all
is not lost
brand new guardians rise every day
to shape the future of our solar system
[Music]
and beyond
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
uh when i think about being the guardian
i think about being part of a fire team
uh for me specifically i think about
being a fire team leader i think about
not only being a fire team leader for my
friends but also for my family so many
of my friends trust me with their
guardians there you go very good very
good oh
you just killed your dad the teamwork
that really pays off especially after a
long period of
hard to come in clutch in the big
moments
i've been able to pass along my love of
destiny to so many friends also to my
family
been able to game with my daughter to be
able to guide little lights is is truly
a treasure but to me the most important
part of being a guardian is being kind
to everyone that we meet your kindness
and joy may spark hope in a darkness
zone where light is fading away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think one of my most favorite
memories with them so far is
valid disciple contest mode it's my very
first time
even doing day one raid
and uh
it was
we didn't get it but
it was a good time
um
yeah through through my clan they've
helped me become a better person
a more confident person a more confident
player and
i wouldn't be the same without them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hi my name is lillian i go by lilybean
cosplay on instagram and i've been doing
destiny cosplay for six years i started
playing destiny in late 2015 and i just
fell in love with the designs
the characters in the game and i went to
a local convention dressed as my hunter
from then i kind of just wanted to keep
going i
did a house of winter fallen drag
sweeper bot soraya hawthorne anna bray
my hunter character from destiny 2.
it always has to do with
a character that i'm drawn to in some
way from a design standpoint if it's a
character that has a bunch of leds or
you know moving arms or something i look
at it and say how can i make this
because i want to learn from it i want
to diversify my skill set with my
spiders associate costume that's like a
fully immersive costume i can't see my
face i'm wearing a helmet and i have two
extra arms
savathun was part of the cosplay
cosmodrome event that bungie did for
bungie day and being able to take a
character whose design i wasn't super
familiar with yet and create it in real
life and then wear it it was great
there's so many different groups within
the destiny community you have artists
you have musicians streamers gamers and
i think that's really special just to be
able to show like
this is what inspires me and this is
what i'm going to do to show that it
inspires me
[Music]
you
so
[Music]
i'm dan aka the rat kings crew i've been
playing bungee games since marathon 2
and i've been playing destiny since i
launched i'm so happy to be part of such
a creative and passionate community and
i can't wait to see
what destiny is going to do next
[Music]
well for somebody who's played from d1
to d2 what makes a guardian
is
someone who
against all odds keeps pushing forward
always making the advance
always moving forward
i was introduced to the game by a bunch
of friends
military law enforcement i'm in the
public safety field
don't have a lot of time to play but
when i play play hard
uh long story short a lot of those folks
either got deployed
went to other jobs or just didn't really
see them anymore complained about
the content and not having it vast
i've learned from d1 to d2 the game has
definitely grown
and
me as a diehard guardian i keep pushing
forward because i have the confidence
and the ability to
see what's happening
and now here we are
still playing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi i'm steve saylor aka blind gamer
steve i'm a content creator and
accessibility advocate and consultant in
the video game industry
my name is t t morris uh people call me
t they call me t monster i also go by
twitch dad
i started uh looking into wanting to
stream i
had known this dude here for about like
i think about 10 years at that point
and so i reached out to him i was like
hey you know what i know you play
destiny
like would you be cool kind of uh
helping me and guiding me through
through the game i've never played it
before this is when i gave you a little
bit of honesty i said
are you sure you want me
because
you see me play so you know how bad my
aim is it'll be the blind leading the
blind and and he went that's oh that's
what we'll call it all right there's the
traveler
there's the traveler in front of us
let's go
walk forward
walk forward i want you to enjoy this
someone who has a disability where it
affects my vision and it is hard for me
to play games in general having someone
take the time and guide me through being
able to play a game and and
not try to rush me through things
that meant the world to me
all right oh there he is
[Music]
in any other game it's usually people
don't want to play with a disabled
person whereas with destiny i can jump
in with tea i can jump in with with my
friends and even when we just jump in
with random blueberries in in in the
community
we can still be able to help each other
out and that's why i love destiny
did you shoot my friend that was a bad
choice it's all about being able to
reach out and pick someone up and be
like we can do this together
and that is being a hero it's being able
to lift everyone else up it's not about
you it's about the fire team that's what
makes a good guardian is when it's about
reaching the end goal and reaching it
together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
hello guardians i hope you are all doing
well happy bungee day here's my ideas of
me being a garden in destiny i started
playing destiny in this new win when the
game first came out i was a hunter man
back then now a proud titan main my
favorite moments of destiny will be my
first ever role that i've covered in lfg
group and the friends and clan master
that i met and play with to this day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm gray or gamer gilgray i am an
indian-american content creator and
community builder on twitch with the
model gaming for greater good i started
my gaming journey in 2014 when two of my
best friends gifted me my first xbox and
i just simply remember finding destiny
and staying up the entire night to play
the game don't get me out let me out let
me out let me out let me know i'm dead
it's not dead yet i found a place where
i could be myself without any fear of
being treated differently for who i was
how i looked how i sounded no no no no
no you've got to be kidding me bro
when i came out to my community it was
such a monumental feeling for me to be
able to see all these people flock
together to make me feel welcome and
safe and included that was a feeling
that
i want to share with other people this
safe space
[Music]
the charities are honestly
a very big part of my stream because i
see my content as a means to an end to
fight for what's good in the world
no god please help me no oh
building a happy corner of the internet
is just about
being able to lift people up in the few
hours that they spend with me
creating
something that people
feel
comfortable in they feel like they can
be their authentic selves in this game
and this community constantly reminds me
that
we're not guardians just a name we truly
are bearers of life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
being a guardian to me has
shown me how important it is to stand up
for what's right and to defend those who
are oppressed and marginalized just like
bungie continues to do every single day
so thank you bunji for being real life
guardians to me and everyone else across
the world the way they stand up for
social justice issues
and make sure that everyone in your
circle is loved and cared for is truly
inspiring
i know that it dictates the way that i
live my life on a day to day basis
thank you so much
and eyes of guardians
[Music]
my name is xavier but you guys probably
know me as solar flare i make 3d
animated skits based off of content in
the destiny universe prepare to return
to being a god-killing time-breaking
para-causal space cowboy at first i
created content that i thought was
creative stuff you hadn't seen before
things that would be funny situations
but i didn't know how to produce them
one of my friends suggested to me this
program called blender and so i tried to
learn it myself i taught myself i made a
video solar flare was the main character
and it went from just being the channel
name to being the name of sort of who i
am at this point okay guys we have to be
careful
someone here is possessed by an owl who
that's the thing we don't
usually it's around 2 a.m when i'm
trying to go to sleep my brain says hey
it would be really cool if we went to
sleep but instead what if we thought
about a new video to create
hey bobby hey stephen
the future for solar i'm i'm really
excited i'm working on a script and a
whole plot a series of videos i'm really
excited to create an actual cohesive
storyline so turns out aldrin's sister
was actually an evil possessed meatball
i was controlled by a magical space
dragon that was actually controlled by a
hive queen
the destiny community feels like a group
of friends that you may not live in the
same area but every time you go back
it's like you never left when you get to
know the people that you're spending
your time with not only does it make
every moment with them more valuable but
also you might find yourself going to
one of their weddings five years from
now just because you decided to send
them a friend request after they dance
with you in a crucible match are you
really going to tell me that looks more
like the letter v than the slice of
pizza
it is pepperoni it blows me away just
how dedicated people are to creating
things in this community it's just it's
just so cool to see how passionate
people are about all of it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here's a guy sarah's universe who's
been in the destiny community for like
eight years of running probably
considered now
considered a veteran
and
the fact that you know
back in july 2014 i was curious about
the game i was curious about it and
you're very interested to see what this
game whether this is the game for me and
then
to to get you know get to a point where
i would you know get so many dungeon
clears raid clears ghosts you know
flawless to the point where i even solo
flawless trials that was two two or so
weeks ago and then to meet
friends like victor tony lovely though
live so then to be a mod for miss kenner
because she's awesome um
[Music]
to have all of that in like eight years
i wouldn't even believe you back then
but here we are
still living the guardian life
amen
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
i want to say one of my biggest
memories about
playing destiny happens to be the raids
and a lot of the friends that i made
that i've made along the way vog is my
favorite raid and when it came out i was
ecstatic
again happy bungee day to everybody and
hope everyone's having a great one and
i'll see you in the stars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody i'm tiege
and i'm a guardian
what makes me feel most like a guardian
is
[Music]
being able to be me
we all choose to represent ourselves in
different ways and when you learn about
someone's guardian the legend that
they've written for themselves it
teaches you something beautiful about
them i strive to create a space online
through content creation that people can
just come as they are we can all just
celebrate in this beautiful world that
bungie's created for us
there's something really amazing about
being able to connect with people
through a shared interest
without the fear or anxiety that comes
with thinking that you have to be
something you're not or think of you
have to conform to a certain ideal or
world view in order to be respected or
loved
so i hope that on this bungee day we all
can remember what it means to be a
guardian
we all can remember to rally around each
other to show the love spread the good
vibes
and push back the darkness
i'll see you out there
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
in a world where you rescue heroes from
other timelines and brawl worm gods with
your bare hands it's a battle of light
versus dark monsters versus metal
everyone versus telesco in a lore-rich
universe with an abundance of adventure
and exploring
but that's not just why we play is it
believe me nightmare hunts give me quite
the adrenaline rush but my twitter
mention suggests you expect more so did
you keep playing for the life changing
gobbles or the mile high sparrow flying
the nessus frogs the day one raid nights
with your friends where you spent eight
hours and still don't know what you're
doing the nessus frauds you must have
had some inspiration right probably the
creators and streamers that helped you
forget that time you dropped your pizza
cheese side down or was it the people
creating a destiny universe of their own
with stories art and literally dressing
for the job they want
maybe you're here for the intellectual
discussion or maybe you're here
maybe you're here for the destiny
creators you love so much bungie
actually got one to do this video
hi mom and dad what i'm trying to say is
destiny 2 is so much more than the game
we see in trailers while many joined for
the fantasy we found a home amongst its
people and in the end game we stayed for
the discos the dps the grenades the bad
bubbles burgers and tannics behind every
corner trombone medley's laser tag tower
names yee haws the dings the puns the
clutcher kicks sweeper bots stasis
crystals cheese spots raid call outs pub
sump ramen sliding chicken petting gala
horns sepik's prime shiny swords
thank you so much for joining us today
uh we are so excited to dive in and talk
about just the kind of journey of being
a massive destiny and bungie fan
and what that's like to go from massive
fan to actually working at the company
that we loved so much i want to learn
about your your journeys how did you get
started playing as a player not as
somebody who works here playing destiny
and kind of how is that relationship
with the game evolved through the years
you know what t you and i we've had many
conversations with session i want to
hear from you buddy
uh so i've been playing the game for a
little bit
just a little bit
uh and so you know as proof of my uh you
know the d1 alpha veteran status i have
my raid belt here today uh
so uh this is this is my cringe moment
where i will be probably nice to see one
in person i've seen it on like screens
and like screenshots
like how did you get it when did you get
it so uh that is
that is the king's fall world's first
belt uh me and my five friends we asked
uh i say used to have but i think we
probably still have it uh world's first
of fun like whenever we were doing
world's first races it was supposed to
be about having fun and showing off the
new stuff
uh and for me i always loved writing
just because like i'm a problem solver
by heart like that's also why i love
working here because what i do is i just
kind of solve problems that are really
complicated that's really exhilarating
and now
is very fun uh being able to watch
others suffer for 24 hours
oh yeah because it is exhausting uh so
if you if you are if you are listening
to this and you are you are rating or if
you're planning on raiding for a long
time drink water stretch bathroom break
don't leave nine please thank you
don't let that heart where you get too
i'm very much with sam on on this in
terms of like the loving the problem
solving and loving to get into that i
really fell in love with destiny when i
started reading and that was like my
moment where i was like i grew up
playing puzzle games and mystery games
and like i love
those types of games and to find that in
destiny and to find
that same sort of like problem solving
but to do it with a team and to do it
with your friends i'm on the same page
yeah i'm totally on the same page like
the the number one story for me around
that is definitely deep stone
like i played all the way through deep
stone with my clan which was amazing
when you look back at the history of
destiny there's so many moments like
that and i'm kind of i'm kind of
interested on is there any characters or
story moments that really stick out to
you from our history i feel like that's
destiny at his best as like
when you are learning from it like at
least for me i feel like the journey of
heiress
from like d1 and being like who are you
what are you doing here this is a weird
change yeah it's like super creepy right
yeah but i think like seeing where
she is now and then how she's like
really helped everyone else like a lot
of people i'm a huge zavala fan i'm a
titan it's just like in my blood
so like for me like seeing aerys like
help all of these different characters
seeing zavala come from where he is
which a lot of people again i i know
some folks that don't really like him
that much but to me he always just
seemed like a really you know father
figure who's trying his best for
everyone uh you know when kate died
right i think like you know people were
like what like zavala why aren't you
doing this xyz uh and then we got to
learn more about him for me zavala is
like number one that like that his whole
character arc and then eris and like her
character arc you're all insufferable to
then like teaching everybody how to deal
with their demons i think that's the
narrative it's kind of crazy
incredible speaking to now and like
through season 17 how eris she's like
one of the epitomes of grief in her
whole story and how she evolved to
something where she's like i had to
learn how to deal with grief on my own
and to see her evolve to a character
that is like helping people go through
their own grief it's bungie what the
heck like how do you do that how patient
she was like the fact that like when
crow would stumble or zavala would
stumble she'd be like
take a step back patience healing
doesn't happen overnight and exactly i
think what we've seen in the last couple
of seasons of
the incredible narrative team and just
diving deeper into all of the characters
i think that's one of my favorite things
that we've we've seen from the kind of
expansion from where we started to where
we're at now is just that deeper dive
and i know
kind of where we're going with things
and just like the more that we're going
to be able to dive into and hear
characters backstories and understand
where they're coming from and what makes
them
i think to everyone's point it just
makes it more than
just a shooter game you have that
additional aspect of these incredible
stories that we all connect with in
different ways and it just makes it it's
the bungee magic it's the space magic
it's the thing that like then you do a
little emote jig at the end yeah exactly
and it all
made sense called glimmer gun
[Laughter]
but like how cool is it like that we're
here now and i'm i'm kind of interested
like
knowing your your long relationship with
this game before you even worked here
and then that we're sitting on this
couch getting to nerd out and talk about
the things that we love the most
how has that been
making that transition what was that
inspiration that drove you to be like
you know what
i'ma put my application in we'll see
what happens oh this is my first gaming
studio for sure yeah it's a
getting into bungie is interesting
because i always wanted to be in tech
that's really where i started for
destiny specifically i played it every
day but i never really thought of it as
a place to work um until black at bungie
uh and so i reached out to a bunch of
people on linkedin and was asking a
bunch of questions i was like look look
so it was really amazing to be able to
like get into
the industry and get into bungie destiny
for me was
uh that was back when i was streaming
for fun it was just a hobby but then it
became just a lot more to me because it
has all these things i love about games
i love rpgs and i love you know like the
the game feel of a bunch of game right
when like you you shoot that gun for the
first time and it just feels good you
know space magic yeah face magic space
and i always play the wizard so i played
in the warlock um you know because
that's all i want to do i just want to
cast base magic in every game that i
play so to me the game's a lot like it's
kind of just it gave me a career uh it
gave me like guidance in life for
finding a community that i really love
um and how i'm absurdly thankful that i
can be a part of the team and hopefully
make the game better to hopefully have
that kind of impact on somebody else i
knew that i wanted to work in gaming i
actually got the opportunity not from
the bungie career website but from a
twitter post
um from
the twitter post and i immediately sent
a message and connected and i was like i
want to talk about these marketing
and now i'm here now you're here
you love to see it so and it's ever in
just even now just the fact that i'm
sitting here i'm just like you shot your
shot dude that's what life's about
literally i shot my
you hear them throw that phrase around
and you're just like but what does it
actually mean to shoot your shot and
it's like no it's like
you're not going to respond on twitter
it's like i'm going to find you in other
places even if you're gonna come and
take down even if you have that moment
of fear because sometimes you're making
a jump like that's scary i'm scared if
you're scared absolutely do it anyway
yeah yeah the leap into bungie was
really similar to will's story this is
my first role in gaming so it was this
like huge
leap to i had been working in marketing
for for a long time but my really wanted
to
make the switch to something that i'm
really passionate about and something
that i love because i think that's what
makes work so magical is when you get to
work on something you really care about
and you really really love and you feel
passionate about so that for me was the
kind of thing that pushed me towards
shooting my shot and taking my shot a
couple years ago and and making the
switch over to bungie and it's it's been
incredible there's moments like this
where it feels very surreal where you're
like what is happening this is very very
just to have that like we all work at
bungie now like we get to contribute to
that thing that we all love so much and
that's
incredible
i'm sorry but that's a such a good point
because there's so many people that ask
us
like advice on how to get in and
i was rejected numerous times before
finally getting that spot
and you know i know it breaks my heart
because so many other people are in that
same position and then they stop and
they stop chasing that dream because
like this isn't my first gaming job i
i've been working in this industry for
almost 20 years and as a journalist and
it was really scary to make that jump i
just i felt like it was right i kept
applying for narrative and you know
granted i sent them
not appropriate fan fiction as writing
people so yeah
no hard feelings i get it uh and they
were like you know it was just they were
like hey we think you'd be a good fit
for community like let's put you through
that interview process and we did that
and it was scary at first but the more i
kept interviewing i was like wait no
this is
this was made for me like this is what i
was supposed to do and it was funny
because all of that trepidation that
first week
left because i i felt like it was family
i'd like to think that bungie gives
space for that human condition that
human element it's a place where i can
feel like i can be myself it's a place
where i am uh being taken care of and
i'd like to think that you know we're
not perfect and there's things we can
improve upon but we try to talk about
those things well thank you guys so much
for joining us today it was honestly so
much fun just diving into your stories a
little bit not just like as devs and
working on bunnyside but as players
before that and the journey into that
i'm really also excited for the upcoming
showcase so i'm gonna need you all to
meet me matt in the back we're gonna do
a blanket burrito and we're gonna hunker
down with some popcorn
[Laughter]
i'm excited burrito yeah blanket burrito
comfortable
[Laughter]
that's all i want in destiny i want
darkness
just got
chills this is everything i've ever
wanted out of the story
oh my god i love it
damn
rope is nasty son
your life is fulfilled no
the leviathan is back a psyche a
freaking sight
he has given himself over to the witness
that was hot
sir are you okay
oh you're nasty
what the prank is that the witness man
that's crazy
welcome guardians
so awesome to be here with you again
last time we got up here
we got a chance to show you savathun the
witch queen and her majestic throne
world
since then it's been a wild year for
destiny you returned to the original
loot cave to reclaim the fabled galler
horn then
you exercised an ancient evil
from a hive queen
so you could put it inside a grenade
launcher
and now you've been spending the past
few weeks cleansing a derelict leviathan
from its twisted nightmares in fact the
last year has been the best year we've
ever had in the destiny community i hope
you can feel it as well
and seeing this kind of reaction from
our community it's both humbling and
inspiring because our team here at
bungie we're not just developers we're
also guardians we're trying to build
what we'd love to play in destiny and
that's what brought each one of us here
brought us not only to bungie but also
brought all of us to this final showdown
between light and darkness
so
without further ado
this
is the beginning
of the end
this
is lightfall
when they see this glorious
they will come for us
to savor the fruitless
to its last draw
it's who they are
let them come and see
they do then
one shackled
from hope
that
is who
they are
because
in the end
are we free
i've seen that thing a hundred times now
and every time i see it i still kind of
get goosebumps instantly i had chills
it's all here it's all happening now
things are finally coming to a head
thematically we really have been honing
in on that kind of bombastic big set
piece approach it's gonna be
over-the-top action adrenaline pumping
like the whole time
this is really kicking off the
conclusion to the light and dark saga
where we finally face down this foe that
we've been anticipating facing for so
long it's pushing it to 11.
we've been hinting at this malicious
force in the darkness that's been our
enemy behind a lot of our conflicts we
revealed that enemy we put a name on it
and put a face on it and that enemy is
the witness
and the witness is coming with its newly
empowered disciple kallus kallus is
really crash landing with a new and more
powerful army than ever before
they've got new powers they've got new
armor they've got tormentors to join
their ranks that are going to be bigger
and better enemies than we've ever faced
callus is taking that army that he's
bringing with him to be the harbinger of
the witness's doom
[Music]
this is such a pivotal moment for
destiny everyone is coming to have a
last stand with kallus and the witness
to really avoid the next collapse
something that we've been trying to
avoid ever since destiny won
we see in the trailer that we're headed
to neptune and on neptune there's been
this hidden city called neomuna where an
alternate version of humanity has been
blooming since the collapse
neomuna is the capital city of neptune
it's a giant metropolis that we were
completely unaware existed until now
what's interesting and exciting to me
about this place is that it's pristine
it's new it's not like a lot of the
places that we've explored previously in
destiny
exploring that space is very very cool
there's so much new stuff to discover in
nyomuna and in neptune and also i saw
some new characters there i'm really
excited to get to know cloud striders
and their story
[Music]
cloud striders can be compared to
guardians they're both protectors of a
civilization that's potentially under
threat but guardians were chosen
it's their duty to protect humanity
cloud striders have chosen to protect
their people there's like an awesome
opportunity for the guardians to learn
from the cloud striders and their way of
living and their philosophy of life so
we've got the newness of that city the
newness of the cloud striders that we've
never been aware of and then of course
you get a glimpse of
this green
energy
i wonder what that is
strand is the new darkness power that we
discover here something that's unique
about strand unlike any of these other
powers we've ever had before when you
play through lightfall you are
discovering this power for the first
time no one in the universe
ever in the history of destiny has used
strand before this is the guardian
discovering darkness on their own
and learning how to shape it and
manipulate it and use it against kallus
and his forces
and you know have fun in the new urban
environment of neoluna you are really
going to have to prepare yourself for a
wild ride we just got a glimpse of our
new destination neomuna our new foe
kallus and the shadow legion paired with
the witness and
a very brief glimpse at strand but
that's just barely scratching the
surface of what this release has to
offer right like what we've just seen in
that trailer is just the tip of the
iceberg and we've got a whole lot more
we're excited to show you coming up
last year we wanted to return to our
studio's roots in creating some of the
best shooter campaigns in the industry
that's been our legacy since halo and we
tried to push that front and center in
the witch queen and it's about more than
just guns but creating an adventure in a
handcrafted world full of surprises
then we added the legendary campaign
option because great combat needs to
challenge you to test your thumb skill
your tactics and your build crafting and
we heard loud and clear that you want
more of that
in fact two out of every three players
that completed the witch queen campaign
did it on legendary you tested yourself
against the witch queen interlucent hive
and rose to that challenge
and then you let us know it was one of
the best shooter experiences that we've
ever made so with lightfall we want to
push that even further we want to give
you the best bungee action experience
that we can create with the brand new
lightfall campaign
lightfall is going to change the way
that our players move fight and explore
everywhere in destiny neptune is this
fantastic destination the capital city
of neomuna is a really fun place to
explore and it's this bright neon
metropolis there's a harbor office
buildings an arcade
this is a city that we've made and using
strand to traverse through it and
explore it it's going to be so exciting
there's some places that once you whip
out that grappling hook ooh you're going
to be able to explore and get to places
that you couldn't before look at that up
there i wonder if i can grapple to there
i'm going to be a kid in a candy store
it's not a city that is collapsed it is
a city that has lived through the
collapse
neptune now has to deal with the cloak
being pulled back and then being
revealed to the world and are now
central of the conflict callus has taken
his capital ship and just like
planted it right down in part of the
city and it's cabal occupied territory
it's a city under siege you've got this
infiltrator vibe at times where you feel
like a tactical team going into a
skyscraper you're dealing with cabal
roadblocks and patrols all throughout
the city
the shadow legion they provide that like
characteristic cabal brute strength
they're all about like volatility and
power and they've been enhanced now by
pyramid technology they have these
suppression devices that can take away
some of your super take away some of
your abilities and then they fight
alongside these terrifying new pyramid
units called tormentors
as part of his discipleship to the
witness
callus has been upgraded and so the
tormentors that they've brought in are
these impossibly huge
unstoppable behemoths they wield scythes
they can attack from a distance they can
bring you in close they can drain your
very life force from you they are
basically embodiments of terror it's
like a boss character within the
battlefield your stomach drops you're
like okay i'm playing through i'm having
fun popping heads doing this thing and
then boom there it is
we've got
all the new stuff going into the game
strand tormentors shadow legion a cool
new environment these are all a great
setting for a new legendary campaign and
we're still making sure that we go
through and we tweak and tune and we
balance the encounters to have that
right challenging level of difficulty
for players the legendary campaign was a
huge hit coming out of the witch queen
it was the first time we had done that
sort of elected difficulty where you
could really test your skill and test
your power and so we're going to bring
that back for light fall of course
you're still going to have that high
reward tier and we still want to make
sure that you get that inside track
towards being raid ready
everyone back in the studio is so hard
at work on lightfall putting in the
details and making this whole release
come alive and continue to surprise and
delight players i am so excited to get
this out lightfall is unlike anything
players have seen before in destiny and
it's another step that sends you
hurdling to the conclusion of the light
and dark saga
[Music]
[Applause]
come on amazing i'm super excited to
dive into strand and talk about all the
new stuff that we just saw strand like
stasis is a power from the darkness
unlike our light abilities which are all
about creation darkness is more about
consciousness
strand is psychic energy that forms this
extra dimension this sort of matrix that
connects everything together connects
all living beings and all minds and you
the guardian is sort of gaining the
knowledge and gaining the power to peer
into this alternate psychic universe and
begin to pull at these threads and tug
at these wires that are connecting all
these living beings
when guardians learn how to use strand
it's almost like this third eye opens up
it's about peeling back the curtain of
reality taking those connections and
then weaving them into new objects
yeah and it's pretty cool to see them
come together like it's always been
there and now that we can tap into it we
can use it for our benefit whether it's
through movement or
through damage
strand has a grappling hook since you're
seeing into this cosmic web you are able
to grapple at any point because the
cosmic web exists everywhere
even if there's not an object there it
will hook on to that web and pull you
forward it's just taking that idea to
the next level putting that uh that
destiny spin on it yep
the grappling hook initially started as
part of the hunter's kit right they're
all about fluid movement rapidly
traversing space and being very agile
but as we were developing it's like oh
man it's this feels like it's too much
fun to just keep it to one class right
so we made the call to expand the super
cool new ability across all three
classes
on the design side we wanted to come up
with how each of the classes interpreted
this additional psychic dimension like
in their own way right
so the warlock they're the telekinetic
master of strand so they're going to be
able to telepathically reach into the
strand dimension pull matter out and
weave it into this big barrage of these
strand missiles
wherever they land these missiles are
actually going to unravel sort of
re-weave themselves into a new form
with the titan you're able to weave
these claws and do an area of damage
around you spinning and splashing
the super i think i'm most excited for
is the hunter rope dart super
the hunter does a flip and weaves these
strands into this rope dart and is
swinging it as they're kind of moving
around
the first time i saw that even in its
kind of like rough state it just blew my
mind
we've learned a lot from creating our
other subclasses and we've taken those
learnings about combat about movement
about build crafting we put that all
into strand and i'm so excited to see
where players take it once it's out
there in the wild
[Music]
destiny is a game that gets even better
when you play with your friends we want
to create communities that are welcoming
inclusive and let you bring your old
friends and make new ones and since last
year over 5 million new guardians have
joined our ranks we believe that there
are still millions more of your friends
that would love to play destiny with you
and the things that you want to see us
improve in destiny are also exactly
what's going to make it easier to
convince your friends to come and check
out the game
it should be easier to create custom
incredible builds
easier to find people to play with
easier to swap from being that boss
melting storm chaser wielding falling
star juggernaut
right into that ultimate ye hang dead
man's tail shooting sightings rampart
crutching sentinel and if none of what
joe just said makes sense to you we want
to fix that too because it's not about
removing the depth that makes destiny so
great it's instead about allowing
everyone to dive deeper with ease
the changes we're making to make destiny
easier to come into changes to how you
build your characters changes to how you
see what there is to do and what there
is to accomplish
and in the year ahead we're actually
making it easier to form groups in
destiny so you can go and do some of the
greatest content that destiny has to
offer all the teams are working together
to build this experience and so that's
what's really exciting we keep on
hearing from players like hey unless i
have a friend to play with i don't know
what to do
and so we're trying to give them is like
hey here's a path to follow guardian
ranks are this like basically like a
knowledge ladder we actually progressed
you through 11 ranks and it's really
like heavily focusing on like exposing
players to all the systems of destiny at
some point the story about you as a
guardian
involves other guardians and what they
think about you that is just a whole new
dimension of your journey through
destiny that we've never really explored
before when you show up in the tower and
you see that person who's at one of the
highest ranks you're going to know that
you're looking at a player who's
actually really demonstrated mastery of
many of the different activities in
destiny
not just from
our perspective but from the perspective
of other players some of the higher
guardian ranks will actually be asking
for you to step up to actually rise to
the occasion
and prove
to other guardians that you are a strong
player and a strong leader
a lot of people have groups that they
already play with but this will really
provide people the opportunity to be
recognized for
helping other people learn the game but
also provide more people to play with on
a regular basis in the year of lightfall
we're going to actually be investing in
building a looking for group system in
destiny itself you'll be able to look
for other players you'll be able to find
groups that are looking for players i'm
so excited about being able to form
groups in the next coming year because
it can be really hard to
get through some of the hard content
solo and making it so much easier to
find people to play with is just gonna
make getting into destiny and doing
awesome content so much easier yeah and
they'll be able to say this is a player
who i can trust to lead me through the
new raid i want to join their group or
they can say these are players who are
new to the activity i want to take them
for that first grade because that'll be
a great experience for them and a
valuable experience for me as a leader
it's really going to help players come
together and understand each other
better when they've never met before
it's going to make the game so much more
social and i think that it's going to
really make destiny players feel like
they're on one team
so commendations is a feature that
you'll experience towards the end of an
activity so you end the activity now and
you get to see the screen that has all
the people you played with you can click
on one of the guardians and choose what
experience you had with them so like
were they a good team player were they
fun to play with
there's no better way to actually show
how good a person is as a teammate or as
a leader than to have other players say
this person's a great teammate this
person's a great leader it's really a
system that's designed to
let players show appreciation for each
other also using the commendation system
people are going to be able to say like
hey this person as a good leader and and
looking at the guardian rank system they
have a lot of experience it's going to
be oh that's the person i want to help
me get through this hard content that
i've been struggling with social games
like destiny give you an opportunity to
like really connect with other people
and do things together and get to know
each other and
with a system like lfg you're making it
so that more people can get that
experience started than ever before
both the loadout screen and the mod
manager are completely new features the
mod manager is meant to make build
construction destiny a lot easier we all
love our fashion game fashion game is
amazing and so we're gonna take what we
did for the fashion game and we're
bringing it to the build craft game
there's going to be one screen where you
can go to and do your entire loadout for
your character it's going to be amazing
so you'll be able to save the build that
you've put together as a loadout and
then switch between those things as
you're going from activity to activity
yeah i feel like with the new released
destiny and the accommodation system
mixed with gardening ranks we're giving
players even new aspirations it isn't
going to be just about power level it
won't just be about gear it's also going
to be about that guardian rank it's
going to be about those commendations
it's all the ways that we're bringing
players together
[Music]
so today we are also launching a brand
new season of destiny 2.
and as we've evolved our seasons over
the years we've learned a lot and i
think we've been able to deliver some
amazing character moments and events for
the community
we're long past the era of content
droughts instead
there are exciting story and events
happening in destiny almost every week
year round and we're not slowing down
each season we want to keep raising the
bar for narrative experiences in any
live game we want to keep pushing to
create unexpected adventures that'll
make every season of destiny unique and
we want to keep listening and learning
from you the destiny community so that
we can create the strongest seasons of
any live service because the witness is
coming
and if we want to survive
we need a crew
we need to enrich our defenses
if you're feeling surly maybe even loot
our enemies we may even need to find a
captain to join us on our next adventure
in the season of plunder
what is the human word
pirates the full vanguard should be
rallied to deal with these
outlaws
well anchors away
now go show those pirates what happens
when they cross spider heads
[Music]
time to blow this wrinkly barge
[Music]
you got the goods guardian
[Music]
sorry getting a little swept up in all
this adventuring
[Music]
what are you most excited about for
season of plunder pirates
season we said what if we just go to the
stars and dig up buried treasure we are
unearthing a lot of mysteries and
secrets we're swashbuckling onto enemy
spaceships and then we're also learning
a lot of things about some of our
favorite characters we're gonna have an
adventure this season
seasonal plunder kicks off with aramus
being freed from her icy prison she's
collected old fallen crews of pirates
and rogue cabal together in order to
hunt down mysterious relics and
treasures it's time to meet your end so
guardians are tasked with stopping
aramis from collecting these relics and
in order to do that you have to create
your own crew of shady dealers and
backroom brokers drifter myth racks
idaho and spider are going to be helping
you anchors away
ready when you are captain that's the
beginning of season of plunder what
you're going to be doing is forming a
pirate crew of your own you're going to
fill it with different crew members that
you can recruit over the course of the
season
drifter is going to toss you the keys to
your personal catch then you're just
going to set out into the stars and do
cool pirate stuff
so excited
this season we have multiple brand new
activities coming that will really give
you a sense of being on a pirate
adventure one of the mainstays of this
season is a new six player offensive
called catch crash
when i saw the concept for the catch
with the big main sails on i just said
oh my god this will be a fun season
just like seeing catch crash through the
different iterations like fighting on
the deck of the ship you get to become
your own ammunition and
launch yourself from a cannon to the
other ship and you are the weapon so
you're gonna go mess them up
the second big activity we have coming
this season is called expedition
you're gonna be guiding a massive drill
that's looking for this buried hidden
pirate treasure and you're gonna have to
be fending off of all these pirate crews
trying to protect their hordes
and then our final new activity coming
this season is what we're calling pirate
hideouts we have so many like different
little maps that you can piece together
fragments of this season and that leads
you to the lair of the pirate lord right
their hideout these are their their
caves where they're hoarding all of
their amazing treasures and their
mysterious relics these relics are
mysterious objects of dark power and
they're all over the system we don't
know exactly what it is they do yet but
if aramis is trying to collect them it's
nothing good
[Music]
taking the opportunity to line the arc
3.0 update with the fall and it just
went up working out perfectly because
you've got all the simple arc weaponry
and the arc shielded captains it feels
right with that release almost like we
planned it arc is a damage type that's
about proximity right it's about going
fast up into your enemy's faces and like
deleting them
it's the the damage type for people that
want to hold w you don't want to retreat
unbridled aggression to the max
hunter is really about close range
action being fluid and dynamic and agile
evasive so we're going to give our
country a new super
we call it gathering storm where you
summon your staff like twirl above your
head and then launch it out and then it
will embed into the ground or into like
bosses or mini bosses or champions and
jolt them like a big lightning strike
will strike the staff and overcharge it
and while that staff is overcharged
it'll start tesla coiling little
lightning bolts out at nearby enemies
warlock is kind of this elemental
conduit you are a class that will turn
yourself into lightning you will create
things out of lightning previously you
know we had this exotic armor piece
called getaway artists where you consume
your grenade it'll make a what we call a
sentient ark soul that fires faster and
does more damage result so we decided to
roll that into base arc soul behavior
any time you are amplified any ark soul
you have from any source
will become the supercharged version
that will fire off just rapid fire bolts
titan's about being this unstoppable
freight train it's about this constant
movement so we gave titans a new
movement option something that we felt
like is going to be competitive in this
new environment of air dodges and air
slams that's a new ability called
thruster it's all in first person it's
all very much in the heat of the moment
you see it happen its whole property is
like rush down or getaway it's a
movement tool to the max
there's gonna be this new melee ability
called thunderclap which is like an
amazing thing where he like charges his
fist off super flashy it's our first
ever charge melee so you hold down the
button and as that [ __ ] back and
charges up you'll end up doing more
damage and getting a little bit more
range
and speaking of like the whole goal of
deleting things i believe in pvp a full
charge is a one-shot kill it is oh yeah
it's a little skillful to like pull off
because you're gonna have to really read
your opponent here
the whole through line with arc is like
it really isn't that complicated it's
move fast
hit hard
and stay alive
[Music]
what i'm most excited about in season of
plunder is that this is really a season
that has a sense of adventure you're
exploring the system you're looking for
pirate treasure pirate relics you're
seeing the world evolve in a way we
haven't done before i love that with the
activities in the season like we just
leaned really hard into the pirate
fancies i love that we have your own
catch i love that you're tracking down
buried treasure and then going after the
pirate leaders in their caves the
interesting thing about destiny is we're
not just a fantasy game or a sci-fi game
we're kind of a blend of both and we
take inspiration when we say pirates
it's old world pirates that you would
see traditionally back in the 17th and
1800s we have like a flintlock pistol we
have an exotic fusion rifle that plays
different than fusion rifles you've ever
seen before it's just like end to end
just really leaning into that spirit of
like the pirate adventure and let's also
make it so that new players coming in
can actually jump in and get started the
gift of the thunder gods is a starter
kit it's a set of armor it's a
thunderlord exotic weapon
so jump in join your friends set sail
become the captain and build your crew
today in destiny
[Music]
[Music]
man it is so awesome seeing king's fall
return to destiny yeah actually king's
fall was the first thing i got to work
on at bungie and i'm thrilled that a
whole new generation of guardians will
get to experience this refreshed and
reloaded showdown with the taken king
so we've shown you lightfall we've shown
you the new damage type strand we've
shown you some of the deeper changes to
the game that we're going to be making
throughout the next year but we have one
more thing that we are excited to
announce today
destiny is coming to the epic game store
today
epic has been an absolutely fabulous
partner to work with they love destiny
and we are just huge fans of what
they've been doing in the social game
space when we first started working with
epic we sat down and talked about the
impact their games have had on us and
they had a bunch of the same stories for
us
they shared stories about playing the
vault of glass and how much they enjoy
the social experiences in destiny
and i got to talk about the summer of
fortnite chapter 1 season 5 when my
whole family was laser focused taking
turns in the island to unlock drift in
addition to launching all of destiny 2
on the epic game store today
for the next week if you download the
game on epic we will give you the 30th
anniversary for free
if you haven't earned your gala horn yet
or you haven't played the grasp dungeon
come to the epic game store and you can
jump in for free
we want to welcome all these new
guardians with a celebration
one that stretches a little further
than the last city
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
a few years ago we shared our plans for
the light and darkness saga
this journey
years in the making is coming to an end
since we started charting our own course
we've been building this story
across five years of expansions since
the first pyramid ship emerged in shadow
keep when we first spoke to the darkness
then
across beyond light
the witch queen and coming up in
lightful in the final shape
we're building towards a climactic
collision between the powers of light
and dark
we've also been working on the destiny
engine behind the scenes
preparing our technology and our game to
last for many many years to come
because destiny 2 is not going anywhere
and neither
are your expansions
we want this story since we first
communed with the darkness on the moon
to be fully playable start to finish
and we're happy to announce today that
we are not planning to sunset any more
expansions
we want the destiny universe to grow and
we're going to continue to do everything
that we can behind the scenes to keep
that possible within our game engine
but enough about the distant future
let's talk about today
the best day all year to jump into
destiny yes
because if you're looking to catch up
right now all expansions are free to
play for this entire week on every
platform
for everyone right now season of plunder
is live and the helm's got a set of
supercharged art gear
for anyone looking to catch up on the
fun destiny is live on the epic game
store you can download it for free and
you can get the 30th anniversary pack as
your welcome gift and if you liked what
you saw about the future
right now pre-orders for lightfall are
live on all platforms and anyone who
purchases the annual pass gets the
exotic auto rifle quicksilver storm
today today is a perfect day to play
destiny
so we'll see you in game
[Music]
i've read about them what is the human
word
pirates
[Music]
what they do then
that
is who
they are
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guardians and welcome to the destiny
2 showcase post show
i hope you're having as much of a good
time as we are because it is so good to
finally share all the things the teams
have been working on so hard behind the
scenes we've got ark 3.0 we've got space
pirates we finally have drifters saying
more than two words
it's a beautiful thing and we've got
some really cool stuff lined up before
we get to that i want to say what a
pleasure it is to welcome to the stage
the one
the only
d flawless hey buddy i'm doing great
thanks for having me it's such a blast
to be here like you said we got pirates
we got arc 3.0 we got light we got so
much stuff to talk about i can't wait to
dive into it and just just go over
everything go ahead and uh give us your
best drifter impression go ahead
pirates parrots i love it i love it it's
gonna be great we've got some deep dives
with some of the developers that are
responsible for the beautiful world of
destiny we've also got a live gameplay
stream later on with some of the team as
well which is going to be a good f
going to be a good time it's gonna be
fun it's gonna be fun hopefully nothing
crazy happens no we love crazy here
we're bungee come on okay let's go we'll
never mind but speaking of deep dives
you actually have something coming up
right i do what you got i got some
members of the dev team here with me and
we're gonna be talking about some of the
new stuff that's coming to destiny 2.
what's going on y'all howdy club
thanks for joining us
all right so let's last time we did this
was shadow keep and
daddo is here and let's just address the
elephant in the room all right there was
a popular meme made
and i don't have a notebook like datto
did i have cards okay so you can't meme
this
all right
how's everybody doing so good happy to
be here man awesome awesome let's go
around the table and let's have everyone
introduce yourselves uh let's start with
uh this lovely gentleman to my left
hey everybody i'm joe uh i'm the game
director for destin 2.
oh hey everybody i'm i'm dan i'm the
general manager for destiny 2.
i'm taylor i am the senior test lead for
season 18
and season of plunder and yeah excited
to be here
hi i'm kat i'm the project lead for
destiny 2 expansions
hi i'm james sci i'm one of the creative
directors on destiny very nice very nice
thank you all so much for being here so
let's let's just kick it off we're all
just talking we're all just having a
good time what are we most excited for
it looks so good did you guys see that
trailer it looked so good i'm very
excited i'm very excited i think i think
in general like uh in destiny we've uh
went to to very different uh
destinations there are a very nature
ascendant uh and i think i'm really
excited to just see what a um
up-to-date up-to-date like super
futuristic neon city looks like uh and
i'm very excited to just use the grapple
on that so yeah yeah grapple yeah yeah
oh i was gonna say the thing about
newman it's really cool because uh as
kat was saying
we've gone to a lot of like abandoned
places a lot of nature ascendant places
places are falling apart or overrun but
new muna is like this uh it's a
civilization that uh the people believed
in and it was worth protecting and it
really embodies like the the positivity
and the hope and the optimism that runs
at the core of a lot of what destiny
does so it's a really cool place i think
i'm excited for how different it feels
from you know where we've been before
what cat and james were saying i think
you know last year the team was sent on
a mission and we said
can you make a really cool swamp
and they're like
okay
yeah and then they're like okay we've
gotten really good at this like swamp
making it's like great
now make a city right like now make like
futuristic like something that's never
been done before in destiny where you
feel like you know minutes before you
got there
it was functioning right like people
were thriving in this place and that's
just a place that we've never been
before in destiny
absolutely you guys killed it with the
design and and did i see this correctly
are we getting destructible environments
in the game uh so
the game is like all about like
blockbuster action you know big uh fun
sequences there and yeah there's
definitely like so some locations some
some places where there's gonna be a lot
of like things blowing up a lot of
visual flair um it's not like the kind
of destructible like dynamic
destructible stuff where you're like
gonna blow like a new path in the in in
in the in the level and be able to like
take a different route than you than you
thought you could but it really adds a
lot to the mood and stuff to have like
these things blowing up all over the
place it really complements the theme of
the release yeah i think for us it's
about you know really highlighting some
of those moments right you're going to
place the rally banner down and just a c
if cabal or rex is going to pour out and
then suddenly glass is flying everywhere
and brands are going right and that's
that moment that we want and then we're
like okay yeah i think i earned that you
know those two treasure chests for my
encounter there
all the explosions
right
i mean that's the trick right like it's
it's a war zone right i know we've been
at war and i know we've been protecting
the last city but to joe's point we just
spent you know the last year in the
swamp uh kind of playing detective and
this is the battle is there it's huge
it's larger than life so there's things
blowing up there's there's the constant
struggle it's just a very different vibe
super excited for the action of it who
doesn't like blowing stuff up
i do
so we we talked about a little bit tell
us more about who who we're going to be
encountering on neptune who are we
fighting
we saw some cabal
yeah i mean i i think the big thing is
you know the witness has as has pulled
in and sent kallus right you probably
saw that concept of calluses you know in
classic style the big pyramid ship with
his own sort of effigy uh crowned on it
and so there's gonna be a lot of cabal
and then there's there's also this sort
of vex undercurrent threat of neomuna as
well and so that's an interesting thing
that players will sort of discover you
know what they've been dealing with for
the past but uh on top of that i mean
you know kalas is back loaded up really
as a disciple of the witness and so is
it really him
i could say with like
97 97 certainty
palace and and not a robot okay yeah
okay yeah definitely but yeah it's it's
it's so cool because uh you know we've
been seeing like a ton of stuff going on
with like kyoto and stuff in the past
few seasons and things and we're
starting to explore like more of the
backstory of like the cabal find out
more about uh them as a combatant race
uh it's just really exciting to see that
happening like the destiny universe
continuing to grow and callous like
we're gonna find out like why he's you
know signed on with the witness what
does he want what's he hoped to gain
yeah but speaking of which though but
like
even though it yeah it's 97 callous and
it's the cabal but it's not the cabal we
know right like as becoming a disciple
callous got some upgrades
so like there's a there's a different
cabal we're going to be fighting there's
different flavors to it
and i think the biggest right you know
upgrade it's not just the cabal there's
there's another unit of the pyramid
coming with the cabal right and the
witness said hey you're gonna need some
help and that's what we call this the
tormentor right right
those things look terrifying what can
you tell me about the tormentors i'm
excited to go up against these they are
terrifying
they are terrifying
we can tell you that yeah so the
tormentors are a new pyramid unit that
will be joining um the
the cabal and the the forces of the
witness this time around um and it's a
it's a they're basically bosses in the
battle arenas that you that you will
encounter throughout neomuna um they are
as you said terrifying to fight against
uh they have different phases and
they're really like um yeah uh scary
mini bosses yeah
it's it's it's i mean we we call them
like terrifying grim reapers and these
things are awesome because they're like
the first like pyramid units that are
like in the core combatant sandbox now
that that you know so that they're gonna
anchor like a lot of tough encounters
and um
they have a bunch of different ways they
can hit you right they have like the the
this like side thing we call them you
know like i said our terrifying grim
reaper so they throw these like side
like projectiles at you uh they can rush
in and like you know like grab you and
stuff and it's just like it's a
completely different experience fighting
them it's a really really fun kind of
like they're living up to their name
yeah yeah yeah
can't wait to get tormented by some
torment
i like how terrifying grim reaper was
the throwaway term
this is grim reaper but worse
and uh we also have another new uh
character type what are we calling these
cloud striders what can we what can we
say about these guys
are they friends
a little background on the story of
neomuna so during the first collapse
there was basically a ship that was able
to escape and that's how the society um
in um neptune started and how neomuna as
a city came to be they basically have
been preparing all these years to avoid
the second collapse and make sure that
all their citizens are safe as part of
that
there is this um this class of people
who actually are volunteers
and it's a very different paradigm from
what we know as the guardians the
guardians are basically chosen by the
traveler to defend humanity with um with
the cloud striders they actually
volunteer to go through a bunch of cyber
enhancements uh and really be ready to
protect the citizens uh in the city and
so that's that's a very heroic thing to
do um and we're going to be able to
discover more of their story and how how
they came to be uh but also it comes
with the cost like they actually
shortened their life span um for about
to about a decade um as they are cloud
striders and so you basically have two
at a time one who's mentoring the next
one and we're going to see some of those
things play out in lightfall yeah yeah
what i sort of love about the cloud
starters is they sort of form this
mirror for the guardian in a bunch of
ways you know we have we think of
guardians as the only heroes for the
solar system but the people of neptune
have come up with a different way and
you know you take yourself as a guardian
you know this you know six foot mystic
hero and then you stand next to one of
the cloud striders and you're like
oh
and i'm small yeah and every one of the
cloud striders looks like they they're
hitting the gym you know morning noon
and night and they have a very different
approach to combat maybe than our sort
of like tactical view or or mystic
powerful view they're they're all force
all the time yeah it's a beautiful
juxtaposition right like you have the
guardians those cats said that were
chosen like you know chosen for
immortality and and but still for
defense and protection versus these
these cloud strategies that opt in to
shorten their own life the antithesis of
of immortality to to sacrifice their
mortality also to defend and it's just
it's interesting to see like to explore
how those two different societies play
out and how that they approach battle
and how they approach combat i'm just
it's gonna be really awesome to see it
play out that's awesome so speaking of
combat we have a new
energy type
strand
tell me everything about strand
i want all the details
[Laughter]
i mean it's green you saw it was green
it's green there you have it
yeah i think one of the one of the
interesting things for strand you know
is it's it's the first power where
your guardian is the first
person to ever encounter this it's sort
of a thing that that you're learning
about and you have mentors that are
helping you learn more about it but
you're really on the front lines of this
sort of new
uh
darkness power and what does it mean and
and then i think how that gets
you know translated to the game play is
this high mobility we really love the
the thought of this the cosmic web right
behind all of us there's this web that
connects everything and strain is about
touching into that web and that's why
grapple can grapple anywhere right you
don't need a point the web is everywhere
you find the web and pull it towards you
and how the different classes sort of
you know
make this web come to life i think it's
going to be really interesting for the
for our players to discover over the
next few months as we start talking more
about it absolutely and it's it's been
something that we've been exploring on
uh throughout the the whole campaign is
also your guardian's journey in
discovering strand as as joe is saying
and how we can learn and utilize this
this new darkness power um is is part of
the story that that we're gonna we're
gonna go through with with players um
and so it's been it's been really cool
as a titan i'm very excited about uh um
doing the titan thing and actually like
have like whole strand and and
have like a whole aoe
what's with all the punching oh they're
claws now they're directed on excuse me
this is a refined punch
um so yeah super super excited about
strength and and i think one thing that
i really want to make sure that we
highlight is what joe said like you
don't need a grapple point to use the
grapple like you can actually grapple
onto anything the air or whatever you
want because because we are using this
cosmic web that uh permeates the the
world yeah that's really good for me
because as a hunter who regularly
overextends himself into like every
fight and it's just like after two
seconds like i gotta get out of here
that grapple has saved my life a lot of
times sweet so we can't wait to get my
hands on the grapple
we also talked about the legendary
campaign in the showcase uh is there
anything new to the legendary campaign
coming or do we exp or can we expect
some of the uh the classic rewards that
we got last time with the uh getting us
raid ready and things like that
yeah i think i think uh from a reward
side you know we're we're following a
really similar story i think we're going
to give you the awesome you know gear at
the end of the the campaign to get you
up in that powerful band we're going to
choose one of the new exotics this time
we're making sure they have high stat
rolls on them uh but in addition because
you're unlocking uh strand during this
we're gonna also give you a little bit
of extra strand currency so if you do
the legendary campaign you're gonna be
able to earn one extra fragment right
off the bat but i think the the
differences really start to come less in
the rewards and more in the campaign
itself um
if you look at the the witch queen and
what we did in the campaign the witch
queen i sort of like to compare compare
that to the corrupted strike right
there's like a little bit of nuance it's
a little bit creepy there's some
mechanics going on and you've got to
play with a little finesse right each
thing is a little bit surprising um
really what we're doing in lightfall is
like the proving ground strike right
you're like hey you want to shoot a lot
of people right like do you want to get
in there and fight just a ton of cabal
uh i think the thing
we're gonna have players go through the
legendary campaign and when you hit that
wipe screen on an encounter sometimes
you see the report and you're like
oh how many
did i do
[Music]
shots fired
i mean legendary campaign has been such
a joy to like you know like to bring
into the uh the destiny you know
universe the past couple of releases
just getting back to that like
that smart combat that you know like
like you have to make choices you can't
just you know be james and russian and
then try and grapple your way out you
know you have to like actually like
think about where you're gonna stand
where you're gonna aim what your loadout
is um you know how are you kitted out
for the for this fight and to see like
the designers you know at bungie like
just spend so much time thinking about
like all the different dimensions of the
encounter like all the different ways
that a player can pick it apart and you
know like the different ways that they
want players to be able to make progress
in it or like push back on the players
um there's just so much like loving like
handcrafted work that goes into
designing these encounters it's just
been so much fun to watch and honestly
just because i'm probably the yeah i'm
definitely the most recent person to
bungee i think seeing that what james is
just saying about the love that goes
into crafting all these experiences as
being absolutely just fascinating and
just endearing honestly
as a as a huge destiny fan and now
having the privilege of honestly working
on my absolute favorite game in the
world um it's it's
it's amazing to see how it all comes
together and sorry i'm i'm gonna stop or
i'm gonna get emotional
sure sure uh taylor let's what do you
what are you thinking about the strand
abilities what are you excited for in
light bulb what do you think
you want to jump into i feel like um
except for james uh we're all titans
here right no warlock wow okay you know
[Laughter]
i think the the biggest uh problem with
being able to see the internal stuff is
you see all the armor sets really early
and they're like
okay what class am i playing this time
yeah yeah yeah especially yeah the
aesthetic uh that is always uh all about
the fashion and like how
how your abilities will like uh
like kind of mesh with
i'm all about aesthetic fashion uh so
it's it's nice to kind of like fit that
in with your subclasses um well fashion
is the real end game right oh yeah oh
yeah
so we
we love fashion we love destiny we don't
want it to end but we've heard talk
about the end of this light and dark
saga what does that mean
is destiny going away no no destiny's
not going anywhere um i think the
easiest way to think about the end of
the light and dark saga is the end of a
chapter in a much longer tale a much
longer book or series of books or
something like that like this is a great
moment in time in the history of destiny
in the history of the world and we want
to tell it right and we want to have it
have a satisfying conclusion but a
conclusion to that chapter not the story
of destiny
i think we've been for a long time we've
been setting up this you know we've got
this big white ball in the sky the
traveler and we've got these big creepy
pyramids coming from space and we want
to make sure that we're always making
good on those stories right we're saying
hey you've been waiting for this we're
going to give it to you and then we're
going to go to the next chapter and
we're going to be able to move beyond
that in the destiny universe and talk
about new exciting ideas
awesome awesome so destiny is forever
you know what else is forever
fortnite
epic
what's going on
i mean
like why wouldn't we want to be on epic
game store yeah right i mean one of the
one of the key pillars of destiny that
we our ambitious goal we try to hold
ourselves to is we want to be able to
play this game anywhere right like and
and just epic games such a huge step in
that direction there's so many amazing
gamers that are over there on that
platform and we're big fans of epic
we're big fans of all those games we're
super excited today to be able to bring
them
like just bring destiny to all those
players who may not have experienced it
before uh you know and and also worth
mentioning if you do go on destiny on
epic game store today and sign up you do
get the 30th anniversary pack that we
launched last year for free
wow forever
wow what a that i'm super excited to see
all the collaborations epic
fortnight fall guys all that but before
we get into that there's some other
things
very exciting things that the
community's been asking uh for for a
long time uh lfgs coming into the game
you finally did it
give me the story behind this yeah i
mean then just talked about it how
important it is for for us for the
destiny 2 team to to make sure that
destiny is like a social game in a game
that like it's so easy to jump in and
just like find you either play with your
friends or find new friends to play with
right and so lfg is really a stab a step
in that direction and so making sure
that we have a really good system in
game where you can jump into your
favorite raid if your clan is not
available for some reason or you're
actually looking for a clan
i think is going to bring a lot of those
experiences to way many way more people
than it currently does and so it's super
exciting that we'll be able to to bring
that in uh next year i think one of the
most exciting things about lfg is the
way the team is approaching it right and
they want to make sure we have the right
foundation because we want a really
stellar
lfg tool in destiny and so you know
what's coming first with light falls is
thing we call guardian ranks
and guardian ranks for us is
it's this journey from the absolute new
new light player
all the way to a grand master like pve
all-star and you can go through these
ranks and it'll show you hey here's what
you need to do next oh you've mastered
that you should try some of this stuff
you should try learning about build
crafting okay you should try getting
into dungeons you should try getting
into a little bit harder strikes and we
think of that as really as the base for
lfg because when you want to go to lfg
you want to know that the people that
you're looking to build your raid team
with your dungeon team with your trial
team with you know you know they're
ready right and so guardian ranks really
is this thing you can say like hey i'm
ready like i've i've done all the stuff
that shows i'm ready for the raids
yeah and
i think between guardian ranks and
accommodations we not only have the
tools that are hopefully going to say
hey i know i can build a good raid team
in this tool we also have encouraging
people to go down and say hey let's take
this person on their first raid right
let's let's bring them up let's get them
up to the next level of guardian ranks
and and so i'm really excited about how
the social team is addressing all these
things because that's really important
we we love
the the sort of unmatched made content
in destiny we want to keep it
challenging and engaging but we also
want to build those tools that are going
to allow you to get into that content
and say oh yeah i've done the raid right
i've done the you know i've i've got to
master some of the coolest content in
destiny yeah i think there's like
a lot of cool elements that you know
like joe's talking about where it's like
it's showing you what you need to do to
you know to progress how to spend your
time another property i really like
about guardian ranks is that as you go
as you move up
it forces you a little bit out of your
comfort zone you know it's getting you
to try new things to maybe maybe do new
things like new activity types uh to try
and uh put yourself out there like a
little more in terms of like uh
you know like the aspirational content
or trying to do some social things
to keep
to keep your your growth and your
journey in destiny like moving forward
at all times and not falling into like
these uh like the the same patterns over
and over so there's
a lot of just really really cool effects
having like a guardian rank system uh
you know that has on the player yeah and
one one of the one of the last things i
think that we're really hoping the
system can do is
destiny can be an overwhelming game not
just for a new player to get into hey
there's so much stuff what should i do
uh also if you're taking a break and
you're coming back and we really want
the guardian ranks to be this place that
you can go and you're like what should i
do there's so much to do in destiny what
should i do and you can say okay i
should work on this wait you're allowed
to take breaks
and i think this is a really important
part of guardian ranks is that even if
you have friends who are playing but
like you're coming back to the game or
you're brand new to the game uh that
that's probably a place you can point
them to and it's like why don't you just
follow like this and it's probably a
great path for you to um to ramp up and
then joe also mentioned uh commendations
and one of the really important things
about building a game that's inherently
social and we want it to be is to make
sure that our guardians are in their
best behavior and um are being super
helpful uh to the community and so
commendations after every match made um
activity is actually something that will
be able to reflect that where players
will now be able to send commendations
to each other and reward players for
their good things that they did in the
game either they were helpful or like
they were really good at pvp or whatever
it was and um and so and so that system
plugs into guardian ranks and i think
it's going to be uh really a highlight
of the system yeah the the once you get
past all of the hey i've done all the
content there's a few guardian ranks at
the end they're all actually about that
combination it's all about saying to say
okay you've proven that you can do all
this now prove that you're a person that
other people want to play with and it
doesn't always have to be that you're
the you know a most amazing raid leader
it can also be that like well cat's just
like super dependable right she's got
like a good attitude and like you look
at her lane and vault of glass you're
like yeah it's handled right like and i
can always count though like what's
going on over there is is uh is on the
up and up is there like a comic relief
one for those of us who are really just
good on chat yes
good backpack yeah they're trying the
backpack that's right
i want the troll commendation
i'm leaving somebody off a ledge
somewhere put it in the game
all right so one of the things we're
going to get our hands on well now
season of the plunder is here
arc 3.0 is here
what do we have to say about arc 3.0
there's so much cool stuff to get our
hands on taylor what do you think um for
arc 3.0 it's it's touching like
at all things arc and so like uh one of
the things that is really cool about arc
3.0
is uh you can bring in uh you know older
arc weapons that
have been your favorites uh mine is
trinity equal
and and like having that like synergize
with the new arc 3.0 um it's it's
something that uh i think we're really
excited to see everyone uh playing with
arc 3.0 being able to
you know kind of build up and craft
their own uh their own uh style and
seeing like what people come up with in
the next few weeks and
i'm just really excited to see how
everyone handles it i'm really excited
for like the titan thunderclap uh i
cannot wait for that titans get another
one-shot ability
i'm just excited i get to throw my arc
staff yes i cannot tell you how many
times i have popped that thing gone
twirling gun after somebody and they
just like like like just like just jump
over me and i just go right off the
ledge to my to my doom now with like
being able to throw the arc staff like i
have like a whole another way to just
like miss and like be totally
ineffective with my super and get
laughed at by everybody
it's like it's hunter struggles hunter
struggles warlocks have a cool new
ability where they turn into a ball of
lightning
[Laughter]
let's just put that in the game
and uh so also blink is back on the menu
yes
how great is that
i mean i'm i'm excited for the people
that love blink as someone that is
constantly
uh the victim of people that are in you
know a pve jumping puzzle like oh don't
worry guys i'm great at blink uh and
then we're just sitting there we're on
the king's fall tomb ships we're looking
down at them and you're like you got it
sure are you sure you're great
oh man so arc 3.0 is here we got
seasonal plunder pirates
let's talk about the narrative theme of
this season uh what why why pirates what
are we doing
i realize i set myself up for the why
not
i mean yeah who doesn't like pirates um
i i think that we've seen time and time
again in pop culture like we're we're
always
so fascinated with like the pirate
fantasy of like
action adventure peril uh a lot of that
unknown on the open seas and that felt
like we could really uh merge that into
the destiny universe and make it make
sense because
there's always looming danger in in the
universe like there's so much empty
space you don't know what's lurking out
there
and i think it's also a really cool way
that we can um
tap into
some some further stories about like
drifter and spider and how they've had
like these run-ins with um you know the
unsanctioned side of the galaxy
and kind of just
finding a little bit more uh to them and
and some
uh
deeper deeper dives into their their
personality and their characters
yeah pirate mystique is is just a real
thing right like and and when you have
to just point before right like we have
our sphere good triangle bad like we
have we have very clear images of what's
on what's on what side of the battle
having something that is neither having
something that is that like you know you
don't really know where it's going to go
and is unsanctioned to use your words i
just think that's really exciting it
just adds a new uh dimension to the to
the struggle and the conflict
and pirates is really like it's classic
destiny like the fallen are spider
pirates it is time that we make good
when you say this is a fallen captain
you're like a captain of what and you're
like love that
you
and
aramis
pirate ship back there
i mean that's a true statement right
like ships or ships are always cool
pirate ships are cooler like it's always
our there's a cool thing about the
pirate aesthetic that i think the team
just nailed for this release so can we
talk about the aesthetic a little bit we
got are we getting pirate hats what's
what are we going to be wearing as
pirates are we going to get to do the
whole the full get up oh yeah yeah we
as as the fashion lover here
we get the hats uh we get uh some slick
coats uh i i am a titan mane but i have
to say the warlock set
is so cool uh we kind of are fashioning
um our armor sets based off of like some
of the
uh pirate fantasy of like captains or
swashbucklers and so you're seeing a lot
of hats you're seeing a lot of coats a
lot of like shiny buttons and like
doodads that are just attached to your
attached to your armor and it's
oh i'm so excited i am
going to
wear so much pirates
all the pirate gear do we get parrots
you know
yeah yeah i i don't think we get parrots
uh we do get crewmates though
so okay did parrots survive the golden
age
someone call julia
[Laughter]
parrots pirates you know
so we're we're looking good we got our
pirate gear on what are we what are we
chasing after this season
uh
a lot of loot
a lot of booty but a lot a lot of booty
here first
um so we have some uh we really leaned
into the the pirate fantasy so we have
uh an activity called catch crash uh try
saying that three times fast it is it is
a challenge
um and it is
essentially you are
having a
uh shipboarding crew and you launch
yourself over to the enemy ship you
fight your way through to the captain's
quarters and then you you know beat up
that fallen captain and
and get that loot
and then we also have uh expeditions and
it is three different activities where
you're kind of going you know plundering
and finding treasure and
glory and then
we also have uh hideouts and
those are
those are
eight eight different uh activities
where you go in and you are
um you know getting rid of some scurvy
dogs uh in those hideouts and you're
uncovering some some long-lost artifacts
uh so it is really kind of hitting home
on that like um
you know pirate adventure of like
getting some some lost uh long lost loot
getting some glory uh meeting meeting
some fighting and fortune in there
super cool super cool so we're we know
we're gonna get some new story stuff
this season we know we get new story
stuff coming with light fall uh but the
the day-to-day gameplay loop of destiny
what's coming to
strikes gambit crucible what what can we
say about that
yeah i i think the you know the the good
news today is that we've got cathedral
of dust coming back to destiny today
we've got you know a new uh pvp game
mode coming soon this season called
eruption
uh next season we are hitting uh the old
competitive playlist pretty hard we're
doing some matchmaking stuff and on top
of that we're getting you know focusing
uh ingram's coming to
shacks which i think will be a pretty
exciting thing and then as we sort of
get into
uh season 20 in lightfall we're really
turning our eye towards uh zavala and
the old vanguard uh playlist with
focusing coming to him we are refreshing
some strikes which is the first thing
that we've done this is not like an old
strike coming in destiny it's a d2
strike that we look at and say
i think those could use a little bit of
love
you may find out about some of those
coming in and then uh we've also got
some really exciting changes just uh
coming to
uh nightfall and stuff overall that
we'll talk a little bit more uh and then
of course next year you know you should
expect reprise pvpn maps and new pvp
maps coming as well yep
sweet sweet
so uh
what else are you guys excited to talk
about i mean we
one of the cool things
from the trailer that we saw that we
didn't get to touch on really we've been
talking about fashion and the changes
you guys made to the fashion
interface was amazing that's now coming
to loadouts can we talk about that so
um i i have a nice story to tell because
i remember i remember interviewing for
bungie and it was like if you could add
one thing to destiny what would that be
and i was like load ups and everyone was
just like
looking at me because again i wasn't
hired yet and i was just like
and then
you know as as we saw well dots are
coming so it's very exciting i think
it's something that like every destiny
player um has has wanted to have in the
game and so i'm very excited that not
only like you can have multiple builds
but also the fashion game is kind of
introduced
in in part of that experience and so
it's going to be super cool to engage
with yeah also worth mentioning that
like much like some of the third-party
apps that exist the loadout system will
be able to pull your gear from anywhere
so you don't have to make sure you're
carrying all the right stuff you can
switch it up on the fly you can pull it
from other characters the vaults etc i
think it's going to be pretty big for uh
player quality of life and just
enjoying the fashion game
very nice i think what james was talking
about earlier when he was talking about
those handcrafted encounters in in
lightfall i think one of the things that
i'm really excited about was you know
playing through the legendary campaign
of the witch queen it could often feel
like hey the tax of switching up what
i'm using is so high i'm just gonna find
one good build and i'm gonna hope that
it lasts and unless i hit a real
roadblock like we're gonna keep sailing
you know with all the the light
subclasses getting 3.0 and um with
loadouts and you know the manager coming
along i'm really excited for players to
you know boot up lightfall
set up
all their different possibilities and
then go into these missions and if they
fail once say
you know what i think i should use void
for this and then just press the button
and be on their void loadout and just
hit that rally flag and be ready to go
that's super cool it's super cool and i
think with all the synergies and mods
that you now slot everywhere i think it
it's it's such a time saver as well like
it's it's much faster to get into the
fun and like even strategize with if
you're playing with a fire team and be
like how can we make sure that like
we're all covering all the things that
we need to cover for each encounter in
each activity so it's yeah super excited
about it huge time saver i'm so excited
for that because my fire team takes
way too long in the tower to like figure
out what they're going to set up and
what they're doing and it's like you
guys let's just go like so i'm very
solar button
well i'm really excited for content
creators as well because i think one
thing that's been difficult you know
people will discover a great building
can be really hard to show off and to
talk about and this is just hey i just
took a screenshot of one page right and
here's everything you need to see on it
right and then someone's like oh okay i
can set that up i can call the flawless
loadout right like that's great i like
that
i might use it yeah no that's that's a
great feature that you guys have added i
know as a creator doing guides uh
sharing builds with the community being
able to just share it on the fly like
that um it's gonna make a lot of
people's lives a lot easier you can just
click of the button switch to an all
strand loadout so
let's let's talk let's go back to strand
all right are we getting strand
everything strand weapon strand armor
like what what's
we're getting legendary and exotic
strength weapons
and i think that's all we can say yeah
no without someone from the weapons team
appearing from behind
they're in the building you know they're
watching okay okay one we haven't talked
about though are the raids so yeah have
a new raid coming out this season well
new you right coming out the season and
then
no one asked about lightfall i don't
know
i don't like on
[Laughter]
yeah i mean raids are like are obviously
like one of our most cherished uh um and
uh in game activities and so it's
something that is coming for lightfall
we'll have a brand new ray the six-man
activity as as they've been uh we're
super excited about that and we'll share
more soon
and then i think the thing that also
we'll play stay pretty cryptic about
people knows coming is that season 19
there's a whole brand new dungeon coming
out right and again sworn to secrecy
here like
you'll find out when you find out but i
think that you know we've been really
happy with the amount of raisin dungeon
content coming out this year we really
want to make sure as guardian ranks and
lfg come on it's always just like a
girth of
pve in-game content for you to sink into
yeah
really nice and
we talked about
the raid um i'm assuming
the witness is going to be tied into
that some kind of some kind of way can
we talk anything about what we can
expect from the witness are we finally
going to learn more about
what the witnesses deal is oh i can take
this one yes we will okay
there you have it
yes we'll find out about the witness all
right anything else you're excited to
share share with us any uh
insights from the team any any tidbits
you have for us
uh i think one thing we haven't talked
about james i know you wanted to talk a
little bit about the the gear that's
waiting from the helm and i wanted to
talk about you know um
today right now if you a pareto
lightfall you get an exotic and it's
from neptune it's sort of used a little
bit of this 3d printing cloud runner
technology technology in this thing we
call it quick silver storm and i think
the weapons team has gone a little bit
wild here because it is somehow uh an
auto rifle that shoots bullets missiles
and grenades
so i'm excited to get my hands on that
and then start start using that so we
can get our hands on that right now yep
yep
if you pre-order pre-order yeah yeah
yeah life operator and the other thing
joe was mentioning you know bringing
players back into the fold in destiny is
always really really important to us and
we know that like if you take a season
off or you you lapse for a little while
you know that there can be a lot of work
just to get you know like get back up to
your to
uh to where you want to be so
uh you know with with this new season
you'll be able to go to helm and grab
like a chest that will catch you up now
so we're gonna have like a full set of
gear in there uh and it's gonna bring
you up to the uh to the to the base
power level for the season we're also
gonna have a special little exotic gift
for you in there so if you haven't
gotten thunderlord yet now's your chance
to grab that and that's going to pair
nicely with arc 3.0
i think what's really exciting about
that gear is it's not just about the
power level um you know these the
the systems team went in and they said
what does a good set of gear look like
for destiny player and so they've set
you up with some legendary weapons some
uh mods in your armor some you know
thunderlord right then we really wanted
anyone to be able to wear this and to be
able to go into you know some some match
made nightfalls and people be like oh
that's good what you're wearing is good
uh and sort of have that confidence that
as you get those better and better
weapons you have this baseline of like
really just competent weapons and armor
to go out and adventure in so yeah we we
got thunderlord coming back and probably
a bunch of new arc weapons are going to
get a nice refresh with the new season
any weapons in particular you all are
excited to play around with this season
like i said i love i love my trinity
ghoul
risk runner that's not going to be a
problem
[Laughter]
sweet sweet well season eight season of
plunder
is live right now you can play it um but
that's that's it all that's all our time
i just want to thank all of you for
for taking this time with me going on
this journey
but right now we have a trailer
we've seen it already let's watch it
again it's the lightfall trailer coming
to you right now
when they see this glorious end
they will come for us
it's who they are
let them come and see
our shame
reveal
what they do then
one
from hope
that
is who they
are
because only
in the end
are we free
[Music]
welcome back andy that was
a lot of good stuff a lot of good stuff
and you survived your first encounter
with joe's glorious mustache i did it i
i hope i wasn't staring too much i mean
if you were he can't see it over all
that hair it's fine you're good you're
good i really liked what you guys were
talking about especially what you were
going through with
let's talk about cloud strider and ark
and stran and pirates i can't wait if
anybody has seen the pirates
you kind of look like preston a little
bit it's a character he's like another
settlement is waiting and i'm like i'm
gonna get my my settler run it's gonna
be awesome it's gonna be epic i'm gonna
destroy enemies it's gonna in the nicest
way possible kindness just structure
them in the nicest way possible destroy
them with love you know the thing i like
about preston is his outfit and i know
you love outfits too you're about to
talk about some outfits we're about to
we're about to talk some outfits uh i'm
excited i'm a big collector if you don't
know this about me i have entire
shenanigans of collectible statues
replicas i'm pretty sure i'm going to
die at a young age because i'm going to
die under hoarding but it's really
exciting so like i'm actually excited to
go into the next segment because that's
where we're actually talking with
consumer products and getting our geek
on yeah so i'll let you get to that i'll
catch you later dope i will see you
later
hi look at that outfit i love it
i love it how are you guys doing good
how are you good i'm amped off of this
showcase man i just want to be a space
pirate dreams do come true facts right
facts all right before we before we go
into this because we're going to be
talking about the lightfall collector's
edition we're also giving away 10
lightfall collectors editions
uh because they're hefty boys
uh this is giveaway is going to be
unfortunately for north american
audiences only
but if you do win in the chat we do the
trip twitch drops make sure you're in
chat and engaging and if you do win it
and you're not in the in north america
that's fine we'll get you a code we'll
set you up we don't want anybody to feel
yeah left out but uh
enough about that because i i need to
know i need to know about this uh this
is epic
warlock i'm titan made myself but i do
appreciate myself a good powerful
warlock i like it
what do you do here who the heck are you
and please explain the beauty that is
your your luck
yeah well so who i am i'm ariel i'm on
the bungie.net team so pretty much
anything that has to do with companion
twitch the website i've touched looked
at
helped out with made sure it's a nice
place for all of our players and viewers
to go to and
yeah see everything about destiny um but
as far as like who i am wearing uh i'm
actually myself i'm my warlock in the
game i mean yeah i'm technically awoken
but i didn't want to wear body paint so
we're just going to pretend that i'm
actually a human we're super pale so i
feel like we could just be like no it's
just a light shader it's fine it's just
the lighting yeah yeah i picked wings of
sacred dawn this was like earlier in
destiny 2 because i just
i really like throwing fiery swords at
people so i mean
yeah and then i picked the optimisty
gear mostly because of the helmet um i
wanted to like murder a broom and just
stick it on a helmet and then wear it
around um and then apparently make like
buttons i don't know
i just really liked the whole thing
together so um also nebula rose best
shader in my opinion you're not wrong
you're not wrong
amethyst male is a close second although
i will say we've had some pretty cool
shaders in the last i'd say six months
particularly like the team made some the
photo finish ones oh the bright lights
i'm just saying it's pretty epic it's
true i like it
and uh
i feel like you don't even need an
introduction with that outfit but like
let's hear it who are who are you
wearing i mean i am our favorite chip
right i made a holiday
queen of my heart i love her so much
yeah i mean she's a badass she's you
know the human who's like i'm not a
guardian but i'm gonna run in and i've
got your bag the whole time
so i i love her a lot she's great and uh
yeah i always want more amanda more
mandalove it's awesome and everybody
watching too it's kind of cool because a
lot of people don't realize that the
same person that voices amanda holliday
is
coyote
oh yeah and i like to forget that right
isn't that like wild like
you're so small and you're so big and i
love both of you it's very confusing and
especially when like amanda the whole
time is like really pissed at kyle
because she's still not over the red war
stuff i mean it's fascinating i get it
if you think about it like you're talk
okay
it's fine you know we heard to make
things not make sense that's what we do
that's that's the beauty of game
creation is you can invent the rules
while you go
i like it but we are here to talk about
the collector's edition we're here to
also just talk about like
we're all long-time budgie fans like
that's the biggest thing is is bungie
what makes it so special is that we are
the players we're the fans first and
then we just make the game on the side
and i don't think any of us have any
chill whatsoever and looking at like i
remember too when we have new items drop
in the bungee store we're all like well
we're broke
but it's fine we're pretty we got cool
shirts and stuff
here's my wallet
so i just want to dive into that with
you guys especially you laureen because
you work with the consumer products team
and you you really have a big hand in
this
we're looking at uh the puka right now
we're finally answering the age-old
question of what happened to that
freaking fish
and so we have it we're good uh what
else what else comes into uh the
lightfall collector's edition
well there's some lore you know but
anyway like besides this wonderful
statue um anyway like the collector's
edition is always a special thing right
like it's it's a it's a good way to
introduce players into the new expansion
but you know it's it's always a a good
way to bridge you know giving context to
what you're going to be doing when you
start playing yes lightfall lightfall
lightfall now a nice like nice plug i
like it
yeah yeah no the puka it been dying to
do something with the puka and uh when
it you know when it didn't show up and
be on light we're like oh
when i won
i think most of the players agreed with
you on that one yeah no no we
yeah so the puka oh my gosh um
yeah what was your question
i mean this is what happens when you get
a bunch of nerds together we get excited
and then we lose track of thought i just
i just want to know what's in the
lightfall collector's decision i know
we've released it or we revealed it
earlier there's a list somewhere
i didn't memorize it i don't want to
talk about that i just want to talk
about the pretty fish okay well we've
got the we've got our lore books like
yeah there are three lower books down
there um with that floor yeah and then
you're gonna get to you know like know
about the puka in the relationship with
the with the stranger um yes we're gonna
we're gonna see something of the
interview like come on when osiris came
out of you know yes decorah has to talk
to him
we're going to see that
it's really it's really good it's
basically prepared i'm trying not to cry
yeah yeah no
it's kind of what i do
oh yeah and there's one more book now
i'm forgetting which one it is like the
it's kind of little
yeah
we're not going to spoil it but like
apparently it's juicy by the way
yeah it's good i'm a sucker for good
laura uh it's good and they're you know
they're your emblems and you know stuff
like that um
but yeah anyway that's what's in there
that's great get it get it buy it buy
10. uh you know i have to buy extra
because my daughter wants it so i mean i
want my own yeah i have to get extra one
because my daughter wants one and um
yeah so no the my house is full of
trophies
i don't think anybody's gonna judge you
for having a bunch of polkas everything
they're gonna just be mad jealous i mean
i have four penguins as you should yeah
i don't see the problem
like it's a negative i'm sharing a
positive
so when we're looking at this liz one
thing i really like and this was the
case with which queen collector's
edition two
is we kind of do weird collector's
editions we don't necessarily do what
kind of everybody else does and i i like
that because our game is is very unique
as well our players are very unique so
when looking at this this is this is
let's let's call it what it is it's
weird but it's like pretty weird like
you're weird but you are weird
what goes into designing something like
that
so that again like the collector's
edition is really special it's special
to
to us in consumer products like it
really it's it's a
it's the one place where we get to play
with
an actual experience yeah we're not just
we're not just going to make a statue
well we did i mean i'll just make a
statue
but it had to be this one um
and uh
i'm losing a train of thought i'm just
like staring at the shiny it's hard it's
it's it's it's like a beacon it's
calling for aid the beacons are lit yeah
you know oh my gosh
what do you guys think that's like
matches your guardian
yeah we called this each other this
morning and we're like yo we got a match
okay one of us has to change okay
i have to change why not twin
when it's fair yeah it's beautiful yeah
i love it i'm gonna attach it to my
shoulder when we leave no one will
expect anything it's fine it's fine
don't worry about it it looks like you
can make it fit there's a spot you could
probably like hook it up into yeah there
is
it's great
i love to like with the witch queen
campaign you had to get the moths you
had to find it and and we've done that
before we did it with the callous
bobbleheads we did it with this we did
it with the penguins we
i
i love it don't get me wrong i love it
because it's cute and i'm going to buy
like 10 and i'm going to have no shame
with that
but
what
what was like you know what there's so
many things we could do
we're going to do this and we're going
to make it spiffy we're going to make it
pretty
what what was that oh my gosh so the
moth is one of the first times where
consumer products and our world team
actually collaborated on something you
know so for human settlements you know
it's easy enough to get like a like
human relatable things you know like a
little figure like plush that kind of
thing but for hive there's no like human
connection in there so what are you
gonna do right but we've always seen the
little fluffy things floating around
yeah but you know what does that really
look like if they try to kill us yeah i
always die anytime i do well springs and
i get hit with one of those i'm like i
didn't die because of an enemy i died
because of a bug yeah
and so we kind of went back and forth
does it you know
it has to be cute it has to be cute and
it has to be cute but it still has to
feel like it belongs and so it's kind of
hard to do thinking of cute and then
you're thinking of hive it doesn't
really connect but then we have to do
the high born plush too
i mean
i never give
we have to find ways to to make it
lovable they're just these aspects of
the world that we all like you know we
want
right and uh in in consumer products we
kind of tap into that it stems from that
love the game yeah and we want to create
beloved souvenirs you know these shared
experiences so it's
it's all about that
i think the reminders i totem some like
joy right an experience it's a trophy of
your experience
but in a way that it's not like
good job you did something
congratulations it's where like this is
cool and then when people come over one
thing i love because i have a lot of the
the helmet replicas that we sell and and
like the stein the guardians gain stein
i'm so excited about that
and i love it too because if anybody
comes over and they see something like
that they're gonna be like okay why do
you have a
why do you have a bug and why do i like
it and then you can actually like share
your love of the game with them and
that's like such a cool connection point
of
of just something random out in the wild
to a game that let's be honest we're
basically married to
so the uh just just a little anecdote so
the the box for the for the moth yeah
beautiful moth there
um well we got to put a screenshot of of
the moth in in the wild right yes i had
i'm sorry i went into the game and i'm
standing in the pool where you know it's
on a little plate yeah and i was just
following it around like you just gotta
be the guy we're gonna take a picture of
to put on the box i'm just following it
around
that's weirdly wholesome i know i don't
know
like you know you're instructors can you
find the one in the pond and then i need
a higher screenshot of that can you go
there you know
you go up the long
way in the throne world and then it
opens into this plaza
you don't know where it is okay i'm
gonna jump into this team no it's right
here
yo
one thing i like about this stuff like
this too and just connecting it back to
your guys's cosplay is
one cosplay is just amazing oh i'm
pretty sure everybody can tell that
bungie loves cosplayers because we
feature them all the time and we have
them all the time and it's amazing but
one thing i like about like the things
like the moth and the replica helmets
and even the nerf gal horn that we've
got which we're also giving one of those
away just saying but we only have one to
give away it's pretty neat just saying
and it goes with your costume and the
cool thing about the gal horn 2 and uh
weapons is they're they're
what what what what are their callers
specifically has to be toyetic toyota i
love that word okay so for anybody that
doesn't know what what what is toyatic
it cannot be mistaken for a real weapon
okay i don't know how many people have a
neon orange rocket launcher so i think
no i think that's yeah i think we're
safe maybe but uh but that's a term that
uh that we learned from our our
wonderful partners at nerf yeah um yeah
so they introduced us to that word and
uh yeah we're totally in
whatever you guys want we're in this is
awesome like how do we convert something
that's pearlescent and you know golden
and metallic and you know black and
it's great to something more toyota it's
great
it's great for us for like when we want
to go to conventions yes because then
you know oh i don't have to worry about
being like oh is this a real thing no no
no no guys it's a it's a nerf it's a
nerf gun let me tell you by the time i
took a real life-sized yolder's hammer
to a convention i had to walk down the
street wait what
yeah you're committed you have to tell
us everything like you do get like
really weird looks like what is this oh
yeah some people kind of look at me a
little frightened and then other people
are like well that's a little too big to
be realistic but um okay
uh i love that yeah i got a lot of weird
looks but uh it's my favorite thing but
i didn't want to bring it you should i'm
very disappointed in you and i hope you
know that chad can we get some f's
please there's pictures on the internet
like i don't i think i'm the only person
that's in the older so you can find your
older's hammer
oh yeah no i i uh i think that's gonna
be
it's kind of interesting too because
when you go to see cosplayers in the
conventions it's amazing to see all of
the things that they build themselves
and
i'm lazy i'm not gonna lie so like the
fact that i wouldn't have to build
anything myself as if i do cosplay i'm
talented enough to do cosplay i can't
even sew a button it's fine but i can do
i can't do a ring and i that's one thing
i did want to talk to you about guys
about because
in the destiny one i love to raid but i
didn't i couldn't do it a whole lot
because i was still active duty and then
destiny 2 i didn't have a group and i
would do look for groups sometimes but
usually i just stuck to the the stuff
that's geared towards solo players
but i remember when i did my first raid
like full completion in destiny 2 i was
so excited and i usually don't
like to like reminisce and be like oh
remember that time i was a badass but
like the raid rings are a really cool
way to do that but i like the design of
we have the new redesign because it
looks very different than previous raid
wings and that's that's cool i want to
like wear a head on my finger yeah
like that sounds metal
um that was actually a really really fun
project for us to work on on on the cp
team um so we have a really really
awesome partner um called rock love uh
they do a ton of they do a ton of
jewelry and they're amazing um
but
uh rocklev had come to us and they're
like hey we're doing this really cool
line of helmet pins i mean we're like oh
we're still trying to figure out what's
the next raid ring what are we gonna do
and they were like well we have these
really cool helmet pins that we've just
done or helmet pens helmet rings
and then we were like what if
what if we just made it oryx's head
is that possible and she was like that
is an amazing idea and just it just beat
a sport off to the races at that point
it was really cool we were like how
how like the fact that we can just put
his head on a ring
it's just really cool it sounds awesome
it sounds epic and it does look super
super metal which is like yeah it's like
taking that model off
actually be heading oh my goodness
i just i remember when we were there was
that
like man i'm gonna
like we're talking like you know it's a
head and she's like i'm gonna rip that
thing off and put it on my hand let's go
but i mean that's kind of what you had
to do to get the whole thing done
because they're you know we've got
people who work with 3d models on our
team and they literally had to like
yoink his little head off and then wrap
it up i love that the wild things you
have to do to like make things work in
real life is is kind of yeah it's a
challenge but it's funny super
challenging with all the robots like
alexa and google and stuff it's like
sorry nsa i'm just talking about work
i'm not talking about actually like
beheading people it's fine i the no
context is
chef's kiss oh yeah i love it with what
cosplayers have to look up and then like
what our job is and like the world to
look like you recently got killed
to get like inspiration for products or
like
i i don't know what they're
like what are you looking up on the
internet and i'm like
you know things
sometimes you don't need to ask
questions you just need to roll with it
it's it's fine
i i kind of got to ask you because i
know like you and i bonded over just
not having any chill ever
at all uh and i i really want to hear
you guys because like for me i'm looking
at everything that we've offered through
the years at bungie store and we have
the guardian cup
uh sign and things like that it's just
so different i want to know if
through the years of you buying
merch because we're fans
what's the one piece that you bought
through the years that just it felt like
it has a personal sentiment to you
because like for me it would be that
first raid ring because that was the
first time i felt like i earned
something
oh
well you know i never got a raid ring so
that's definitely not going to be it
just kidding
um
i mean i mean and i've been a part of
like the bungee and destiny community a
very long time i have like 16 years on
bungie.net it's disgusting
or amazing i don't know
but
there's a couple things like first that
comes to mind it's kind of sad but um
my favorite piece was the warlock um
rock i think they were rock glove right
the earrings but i can't find them no so
they're gone but they were my favorite
and then i actually just bought the
um the helmet the
celestial night helmet for my mom yes
because we played destiny together and
um
she's a warlock or a hunter sorry she's
a hunter unfortunately but um so i
bought it for her and she was so excited
but if you could please put a warlock
helmet in the shop that would be great
because i don't want to make another one
i see you looking them here
i
kind of think it's probably my d a c
jacket because i remember
my hand i know
was that yours no
i think i couldn't get it what's your
most so yeah
my dvd jacket was like i worked hard for
that bad boy i wish i got the vow jacket
though the val jacket's nice i love it i
love
uh yeah no i just
over my head forgot but yeah dsc i think
was my first rate i did and then we were
doing it every week we got it down to
like 45 minutes at one point heck yeah
yeah we just think we're winning
you know we take those wins what about
you
people are going to hate me for saying
it and nobody but i have
the srl track jacket yes
it's my surprise yeah
we can't talk about that
i'm sorry
we like sparrows we like to race or in
my case just falling off the cliffs yep
correct
on the sparrow in the world it's all
this noise
y'all just causing all kind of ruckus
i'm trying to rest what andy we you
can't
you can't you can't we're doing a
showcase you can't a showcase yeah we're
live you can't we're destiny we just
revealed this fall arc 3.0 season of the
plunder oh that y'all did that thing did
you not see the trailer no child i was
watching my stories thank you guys so
much i gotta we gotta go learn miss anti
here thank you guys let's go let's go
watch the trailer oh we got a trailer
let's go we got a trailer let's go watch
the trailer we're good we're good thank
you guys so much
[Music]
what is the human word
pirates the full vanguard should be
rallied to deal with these
outlaws
well anchors away
now go show those pirates what happens
when they cross spider heads
[Music]
hope you've got ammunition guardian
time to blow this wrinkly barge
[Music]
you got the goods guardian
[Music]
[Music]
sorry getting a little swept up in all
this adventuring
[Music]
how epic was that trailer i mean come on
space pirates come on space pirates it's
amazing we love it but now
even though we've had some amazing chats
we got to talk cosplay we got to talk
collectibles we got to talk galley we
got to talk arc
it's great we've got a lot of cool
things that we're excited to show you
guys excited for to get your hands on
but what we're really excited about what
i'm personally excited about
i'm not talking about the game let's
just play season of plunder is live now
so we're actually going to sit down with
some of the devs who helped create this
universe and see
them fail hopefully because it's going
to be funny and then also just seeing
what they do and how they build their
perfect arc 3.0 experience so
let's just let's just get into it let's
uh
throw it to our team
oh yeah baby it's a pirate
party how we doing we got some members
of the dev team huh
and right up here what's so funny why
y'all laughing at home y'all you got to
what's up
same page as long as you keep it groovy
you know what i'm saying
how you doing well baby won't you go
ahead and introduce yourself to the
people at home yeah uh i'm will i'm i do
marketing here at bungie for destiny 2.
um right now i'm really getting ready to
dive into
this warlock arc 3.0 become a
thunderball and oh yeah that's when
you'd be shooting that lightning out
your hands yeah no not just from the
hand but like my whole body i
move forward and i'm lightning so it's
like when the grooves take over you just
can't hear heal but you know what i'm
saying exactly all right will baby and
we got andy right here what's going on
baby hey how's it going man
how you doing we got we got we got d
flawless on the lawless seas man what's
like this is this is a pretty good way
to start the day oh come on you know i
got to get my pirate on
i need my plunder oh you never stopped
you never stopped man never stop tell
the people what you do add munchies yo
everyone i'm i'm andy i'm a full-time
hunter and i also work on the social
media team here at bungie
and i'm better than a titan
very fine very fine and right over here
we got my main man ray what you say baby
how you doing not bad not bad yeah uh
i'm ray uh i'm one of the test leads for
the season and i'm looking forward to
rocking uh an insurmountable uh skull
fart to try and go infinite with the new
titan melee oh yeah we gonna be showing
off all this awk 3.0
how you doing leanna uncle how you doing
oh you know i'm groovy at always where
did auntie go oh she she round here
somewhere child you know she always mad
at something
we showed her a trailer she got excited
and then just just disappeared and she
probably went to go play the game
knowing her that's fair that's fair
speaking of playing the games nick
hey how you doing i'm doing all right
i'll keep my fellow titan because titans
are the best classes yeah i'm i'm
relatable i'm nick arderzoni i'm
narrative lead for this season and i'm
going to be doing the trademark titan
thing which is missing my thunder
crashes yes just going off somewhere
real talk yeah you got it real i feel
like that's the experience if you didn't
miss your thunder crash are you really
playing titan you can count on me
i know it i like it
allie how you doing i'm good you're
rocking the wall you're rocking the
space magic oh always you know
yeah um i'm ally i'm on the consumer
products team as we just chatted about
but yeah i'm bringing my favorite exotic
back in the game baby crowd of tempest
let's go
ready i'm going to be a sparky boy the
sparky boy i like it you got to do
amanda proud though you're you're
rocking her colors man you got to do her
proud i know i know can't disappoint our
favorite mechanic you know i got i gotta
make a proud i gotta have a good sparrow
man
and last but not least you guys always
hear us talk about uh intubs about
player support and how they're the
heroes that don't wear capes but they do
have spiffy hoodies and in this case
especially shaw to get their pirate on
yeah how you doing
good good um hey i'm leah i'm an analyst
on the player support team and i will be
rocking the uh liars handshake hunter
build today so dodging and punching
dodging and punching okay okay are you
guys like super stoked uh to get your
pirate fantasy on oh yeah i can i just
say
drifter humming sea shanties is not some
it's like i didn't know i needed that in
my life right until we saw the trailer
and i'm just like where has this been
it's like an epiphany right like i
didn't know i needed that but now
everything in the universe suddenly
makes sense
you'll love to see it and maybe hey
uncle you're the dance king you gotta be
the seashell dance we could do that i
call that the sea shashy
okay let's go let's go let's go oh wait
you got a sword though man i think
so come on now yeah let's go
you know what you know even though uncle
got this short defunct is the only
weapon i need
okay
you don't need a dance partner if you
got a sword apparently i like it or a
rapier i'm sorry for the the weapon
enthusiasts out there connoisseurs if
you will i want to see these players uh
what they got to show us i want to see
some mark 3.0 and i want to see some
cats crash
all right andy i got to make fun of you
buddy
what about this flawless play what are
you talking about uh yeah yeah yeah i
can't wait to see you blow yourself up
one of us is at the lighthouse this
weekend that's all i'm saying hey hey
fair
uh we we love our andy here uh he
recently joined us over on our social
team with griffin ed
even though he's a little bit
confused because he's playing hunter
okay we still left him anyway
actually that turned out well actually
all right better than expected right
it's true absolutely we can dab to that
my dad partner in crime i love it uh
you came at an interesting time you
joined us right when we were wrapping
everything up yeah as all this stuff was
really getting ready to launch off it
was like alright andy here's everything
and i was like as a destiny fan i was
just like quietly just like losing my
mind behind the desktop every day like
oh my god i get to just see all this
right away it was it was very to my dad
who i play with a lot it was tough
keeping that close to the vest right
they flying into the game oh it's time
all right so what are we doing we're
going to go into the new activity of
catch
catch crash look can't crash are we
going to are we going to destroy i want
to go play this i'm going to let y'all
get to it i'm going to be right back all
right sounds good sounds good he's going
to go get his dance on
we're going to get our explodey on at
our art gun i'm excited and they say
that people
that can't do teach
that is there's a reason i'm not the one
playing
but i'm stoked to see you guys this
builds i feel like a solar
3.0 like for me void made sense because
i i'm avoid maine so i was like okay i'm
ready to like squeeze every juice and
solar i've never really felt solar like
i did with void so it took me a little
bit longer but then when i found that
build
it was like god it was like
it was amazing it was incredible it's
like this one i'm actually excited about
because when i did play warlocks i
played all three characters share the
love
the the the i'll give you that the right
that's good
flawless where have you been we have a
showcase to do i don't know apparently
my auntie was here
and my uncle i hope they didn't do
anything to embarrass me um if they did
i'm sorry
um
what are we doing a little catch crash
here
we're getting repaired on oh yeah i'm
excited too because we've got um nick
here which you saw earlier on the stream
and he is our narrative and he's
brain is incredible like the amount of
things this dude does is incredible with
his team
and he also rocks a fake mustache very
nice but you don't get to see that this
time maybe next maybe next showcase hey
say the thing
say the thing
and say the thing level now pirates yeah
there we go
let's go i love it very nice so uh we're
showing off a little arc 3.0 and catch
crash right we are we are we're gonna
board some pirate ships we're gonna
recruit some uh pirate npcs to do some
damage
uh i like this because okay so i'm
anybody that's ever played a shooter
with me they know like there's chaos and
then there's me like there's no arrival
reason like i'm the one that shoots
everything and they're like where's her
aim i'm like you don't know what i'm
aiming at i'm eating at the floor i'm
leaving up the sky i'm hitting my chest
and it's really cool because like all
those times you see in the game you see
all those ships but you can't really
actively engage in them they're just in
cut scenes and now
you can board them you can take them
down you can show them who's boss and
it's but there's an interesting
narrative too we've got menthrax backs
uh i wanna i wanna hear from you like
what's what's what the hell is going on
man so much stuff i can't say on day one
but aramis aramis is back in the game
something woke her out of her stasis
prison okay and um she she gathered some
of the ancient pirate the elixir pirate
captains and uh we need to find people
who know something about that so we
talked to our old buddy mithrax mithrax
talks to his old buddy spider and uh
midheax is involving uh his daughter ida
this season she's uh she's scribe of
house light you may remember her from
season of the splicer yes um
and
and drifters there singing the
soundtrack the whole time so as he
should i love it as he should it's about
time we finally started appreciating him
in all his full glory okay the man has a
voice of an angel
an angel
yes it's amazing i love it and we're
showing off let's see here one of the
cool things that i wanted to see even
though i'm a hunter main and we're going
to get to why hunters are so awesome
we're going to address that because
that's you know we can save the best
friends is this where friendships end
i thought we had something
tested at the very least yeah we're
testing we're testing boundaries here
one of the cool things i wanted to see
in action warlock has this cool ability
to just turn into a ball of lightning
yeah that is really cool actually will
show me show me how this thing looks in
action yeah you just well let me see if
i can get a right here okay so we're
gonna slide and melee and they just
killed it for me but i just did it
thanks everybody i promise he did it yes
i became a lightning bolt
i promise okay well we'll try we'll come
back around i want to see this thing
take out some take out some bad guys
anything else we showing off today i see
a jug shield over here
jug shield is back
dude everything's back
the world doesn't make sense anymore and
it's glorious
all right lee
what are we doing
oh try not to die to these turrets oh
you survived a thunder crash or is that
your team nevermind
[Laughter]
dude i've had so many i think i work too
much and play too much destiny because i
actually had a dream the other day that
i was being chased by this floaty boys
but then i shot them and they like
exploded yogurt and it was really gross
and weird and awkward and it's yeah i
don't know why i brought that very
disgusting fun refreshing twist
i can't imagine anything in a spotty boy
would be fresh it's probably like
turtles but who doesn't like a good
yogurt
that's fair it's good for the digestive
track okay
it's good it's good uh i want to talk to
dee i want to let them play i want them
to they're going on a boss fight i want
to see what they're doing i want to hear
from you though this is your first
showcase with us
and i you you've got to actually talk to
leadership and the people behind it like
looking at this now
what are your thoughts on seasoning
season of plunder um i literally just
cannot wait to get my hands on it i'm
jealous of all these guys sitting here
playing right now
i just wanna you know i wanna
blink as a hunter i wanna try out the
new super i want to jolt people i want
to run fast i want to hit people in the
face i'll play a little titan warlock
but you know you know i always come back
home
it's okay it's okay you know i'll
convert you i'll just i'll change you
i'll make you better okay
we'll see
but no it's been a blast this is
incredible love talking with the devs
and all their insights and everything
they had to ask i'm just so happy to be
here and just see all this
going down live and
my clan and i were talking when we were
watching the actual main showcase and we
were all hanging out i was i was talking
to my client on discord and they were
just losing their minds i mean talking
like totally like non-coherent
we're making a lick of sense which
really typically isn't different than
usual but in this case it actually did
make sense but i'm like excited because
these kind of activities
i know you know sometimes they're not
for everybody everybody comes to destiny
for a different reason but i like these
activities because one they keep me
coming back it ties into the overall
story and it's just a cool thing to run
with friends but if you need to you know
go with other people or if you want to
just kind of go with brandon's or
whatever if you want to cry
you
all this guardian on guardian violence
it's violence man
it's great can i watch this one
dude that looks so sick though
i like how like hunters are like
ballerinas almost oh
they're like they're always known for
movement but here i feel like something
about the arc makes it majestic graceful
lightning ballerinas
you feel pretty is that oh that's why
you like hunter you're like i want to
feel pretty i deserve this i do we do we
all do you do it you do you do i like it
i really like the i like i know as soon
as we get to play as soon as we get to
play
i'm not even going to start the missions
or anything i'm going to get all the
armor and i'm just going to be like five
hours and
yeah get that
you got to get the fashion just right
and we got the fortnight fashion we get
to play around with
okay so funny story
the best kept secret
i know nobody knew about it going into
this showcase you know we're just really
good at secrets here so if you have any
hit us up
uh but i like it because like before i
joined bungie i was a journalist and a
big focus of mine for a couple of years
was writing like fortnite guides and
getting in there and having to like know
all the nuance and so it's so cool now
to come here
and we actually like have an official
collaboration it's here and i'm not
gonna lie that warlock drip for
fortnight is is dope
it's so good
like if you want to take me off of a
hunter lead with the warlock fashion i
mean
they're looking kind of drippy you gotta
do it man you gotta do i
you can't fight crime if you ain't cute
right and i don't care i'm i am
absolutely the player that i'm going
into a raid or something like change out
to do this change out to this
and uh
you will be able to uh
change out of whatever and you get the
load out and everything but
with me it's like i don't care if this
doesn't do anything for my procking
i just want to look pretty i want to
wear the crown of tempest it doesn't
matter if i'm running solar
looks like will's got some uh some
action going on over here what are we
getting into are we almost up on our
melee uh now i am okay okay now we just
need to get to some enemies so that
hopefully i can you know get one or two
now we're gonna become the lightning
while we're waiting for that why don't
you tell us what you're excited about um
i'm really just excited as a a lifelong
warlock um i'm just excited to see how
arc 3.0 just really plays and figuring
out what my next build will be um i'm
really loving uh the sniper
um drawing a blank because okay cloud
strike cloud stream thank you um shoot
stuff and make stuff go boom exactly
electrocute them blow them up you know
thunder from above
why not
beautiful beautiful
all right so we are
we have head to the bridge we're waiting
for some enemies here
little dance party a little cat dance
going on it never stops
uncle was here earlier we got the [ __ ]
we're ready uncle you know he wasn't i
told him to stay in the car all right
fair all right
he decided to
he decided to come in on his own so um
man about town i'll have to talk to
uncle and auntie apparently she barged
in earlier but she said justin did she
catch her stories in thailand
all right okay i'm just gonna assume i'm
gonna assume that's all right that's
fair
uh
[Laughter]
oh no the cat dance man that feels
personal
that feels personal man
that
the cat dances like the kryptonite
everybody does this to me in my clan
every time i turn a quarter
i can't it's it's
it's it's intimidating and it has no
right being not intimidating you're a
cattier dance man no leona i think
you're wrong it's the best emoji it is
i'm sorry yeah you're sorry hey two ally
yeah i'll just do it
i feel like as much as we dab i'm so sad
i missed the dabbing emo
i feel like that was that was made for
me you know why why use the emote when
you could just dab in real life
it's what we do that's called a segway
that's called
that's called us away
i like it all right looks like we're
loading up our second game here and you
guys are playing on your own characters
like these are your characters that
you're used to
nice this is my baby
nice you're beautiful oh my beautiful
haunted house i love it fashions i love
it
you don't see that a whole lot anymore i
like it
it looks very medieval meets face magic
you just got a match you're down man
it's true it's very true so uh so what
did you guys think about catch crash how
do you feel you think the players are
gonna be excited to get their hands on
it i love it it's it's one of those
modes where you can just like literally
go in and it's that there's different
things to do and you just attack and
it's just like full-on jump to a ship
and just yeah
definitely going in for the whole
pirates and you know just pirates
plunder
and all of that you've got a dead man's
tail at home with way too many kills on
it it's just gonna get way more honestly
like all these these shanks are just
waiting and that's kind of a pirate
weapon right
it fits right okay i need to i'm kind of
disappointed in you guys like honestly
because
we've made it through an entire activity
and i haven't heard one pirate
so like we need to fix this liana what
are you waiting for
you're never disappointed you're never
disappointed
look at this loading animation this
loaded animation is so so exciting
oh my goodness look at how beautiful it
is
it's true i don't know my robes would
like to differ nick i fight me i can
wear i don't like back roads in
hey at least we're comfy gosh having
such big shoulders how do you get
through doors you wear formal gowns i'm
just who is this jugger not tight it's
giving me flicks
because we're big boys is this you it's
beautiful are you the judge or not
i'm i'm just the guy who goes
and then punches them super hard they've
walked behind me by the time i get my
punch off but gotcha i try the real
question is does anybody have galahorn
does anybody have galloping
okay
i want to see some gal horns because i
want to see who blows themselves up
first
because it's going to happen
why would you even say that because it's
it's self-fulfilling for hopsy man
you've played with me you know how i
deal with that place your bets in chat
who's blowing themselves up first
themselves up and also for chat since
you're here uh you want your own gal
horn we have a nerf gal horn that we are
giving away again sorry it's just like
the collector's edition this is a north
american opportunity only just because
of shipping reasons and also you know
it's really hard to explain to customs
what a galliforn is
uh but if you if you get it
and you're not us you're good
you're good we'll get you something else
to make sure you feel when you're in
your baby you really want something
i love it i want to see like you guys
are so like cohesive too
usually i'm like the blue dot that
they're like where'd liana go
i'm like dead off
somewhere
it's totally normal
i like it i like it so
what i'm seeing is the spiky sonic bros
body pillows in our future maybe liana
stuff believe me
this is a personal call out to me me and
me
look maybe one day we'll work on it
dreams do come true we just gotta
manifest isn't that like the tick tock
thing manifest it's fine it's totally
fine
i love it so how are you this is your
guys the second one how are you feeling
do you feel like the second go is a
little bit more
you kind of know what everybody's play
style is
i'm just here for chaos
the trajectory just didn't line itself
up
it just reminds me of that one was it
inverted spire where you used to just
like smoosh your face right here
all i heard was
[Laughter]
i'm so excited this is
this is just great i think perhaps i
don't know new seasons always feel
really exciting but i feel like this one
is
i don't know it feels special just
because i think we've seen people want
pirates for so long but because it's
such an out there idea for space magic i
think that nobody actually thought it
was going to happen pirates hit
different they do hit different they do
hit different and uh these are nice
pirates because we're a t-rated game
but they're still booty there's still
booty there's booty there's an excuse to
make booty jokes and honestly that's
that's what i live for
yes
get that booty do he got that booty
though he knew
where did my friends go
from the door joining
[Laughter]
the little diamond told me
i have faith in you
i hope you get squished don't give up
what's these glowing orbs we're seeing
these glowing orbs what what is that
these ones yeah they're like the mini
bubbles yeah so they protect the boss
when he gets to a certain level of
health so we have to blow him up so we
can get him more nice so this is a
really team dependent activity yeah
everybody needs to be on the same page
do you feel like it's kind of easy to
get into the same page with this like is
it intuitive well there's two of them
here so you know if you split in a two
maybe you can uh be more timely wait
there's two walkers yeah there are times
yeah yeah
what double beds
double the pain double the fun you know
that's cool
that's okay we're not you can't
this just feels satisfying like watching
nick with the freaking
launcher
just floating around like a butterfly
because titans are the true epitome of
grace
i know i'm not here let's see this new
hunter super hunter super let's go wait
for him to
wait from the moment you got to take the
shield
hold on
cassie
all right jumping alongside leah here
she's got an active super the boss has
their shield up working to get it down
boom the shield goes down leo
[Applause]
combination blue and you love to see it
you see the electricity
we need to see more of this who's got a
super up i want to see more actors
at the same time and he's got one and
let's it's are you hunter also
so nice play it twice all right let's
drop this
let's drop this shield and show this
super up or just shoot the shield that
works too i thought we got the last one
andy throwing for content
you know i had to make sure everyone
else could like feel comfortable around
me such a pro
please thank you
okay it looks like ray's getting close
will's got one got one
are the shields actually down before
they are now they are now shielded down
what's your build look like for 3.0 um
i'm really thinking i want to try out
the lucky raspberries
um
i hear that they're already great i was
playing around with it before the new
season dropped yeah and you know i got
some secrets i got some tricks up my
sleeve that i may or may not be posting
on some you know what we'll talk about i
heard nothing
but yeah lucky raspberry being able to
chain those enemies get
your super back really fast get your
energy back really fast uh clear ads and
also uh i want to get my hands on liar's
handshake that's going to be real
as a hunter and i'm just never taking
blink off it they gave it back to me my
baby is home where she belongs you keep
that close
you cherish it you tell it
and that you value it
it's it's great what about you what are
you uh what are you gonna be rocking i
want
okay so for my titan i i already know
falling star we already talked about it
i can't wait to biff so many thunder
crashes in the future it's gonna be
wonderful
okay looks like ray's got his uh his
melee up you ready melee let's do it i
just need to find somebody to punch into
it
all right so ray's going to find
somebody to punch in the face
all right
let's see please don't make me this time
yeah
engaged
[Laughter]
you had that one coming though so in
fairness yeah i didn't have coffee i
guess
it's part of the territory
there's multiple levels all right here
we go let's see this super all right
oh that's cool that is really cool i'm
going to be playing
oh boom he just
what
oh you got that thing on fast cooldown
yep what are you doing beautifully
[Laughter]
okay
insurmountable skull for it there you go
you see him you're seeing the tricks and
and tips right here you said dev
that's one thing i want is i want
everybody accuses us of dead blue
then explain why i still don't have
hearthstone okay why don't i have i took
me what
a long time to get backs but it was
really pretty when i got it i felt so
accomplished i was like dude that was
worth it it was good it was like the
second time i want the devil that's one
rumor i want to be true make it true
please for the love of god
oh wait i want everything yeah that
titan punch looks pretty deadly i can't
wait to go up against it in the crucible
turn around how are you doing my love
i'm doing great i'm i'm just okay hold
on here we go i'm just trying to teach
you i'm trying to become a thunderball
because we just punch each other
so after this we're going to do one more
game of catch crash here we go
and uh wonderful man this is looking
really fun can't wait to get my hands on
it for anybody still watching make sure
to use the drops for the twitch drops
that we've got we've got that shiny new
emblem that you can earn
we're also doing giveaways for the
collector's edition we're doing giveaway
for the nerf galahorn for north american
players
and uh
feel for us because we want to be
playing right now it's really hard to
watch everybody else have fun okay
let's push somebody else
if sparta kicked somebody like no it was
an accident i don't know what you were
talking about i didn't just kick that
person out of the chair so i could steal
their character
and who's got the new exotic fusion
rifle yeah i'm wrong with that okay
you've got it so tell us a little bit
about this thing i i love if i'm
responsible i would go in and read the
perks but to me it feels like when you
just hip fire it it goes like this
and then when you zoom in and fire it
goes like whew
there you go
if this is the oolu
campaign
that's the official language
dude
this looks so good
i can't believe we get to like just
board ships and take them
that's awesome
that's epic dude like
pirates are cool i don't care who you
are how old you are pirates are freaking
cool
do you know any c chances
[Laughter]
because i don't i don't know
what's the one from from the the game
with the thing or it's like
don't know the lyrics too this song
is that it is that it that's the way
it's right i'm going i'm following your
lead
and i know like everybody else is
probably mesmerized by the beautiful
angelic voice that just came out of me
that was that was epic
she had a single tear
i also really like just side note not
game play related but the little fallen
mugs
are more freaking inspiration happening
the smalling are so freaking cute man
it is the best keep going all right so
it looks like we got a boss coming up
well it appears that aramis has hijacked
yet another catch crash for us
it's pretty it's not like a super long
activity tune so which is nice for when
you're getting those resets something's
loading so this is the uh the great
loading pass time of guardians oh yeah
we're familiar busting a move
that's how you make friends the tower
friendships of emotes are the best types
of friendships we've got a little i got
to make sure i use the right language
here we got a worm
we got the sword fun's over everyone i
saw a little uh
fancy dad dance
did you do the dance i do like our
dancing moments we have some pretty cool
looks like you all have to go together
to the bridge
all right
let's kick some flat all right so let's
move to the bridge everybody all right i
want to see
titan smash
i want to see us take down these bosses
what do you think show the people at
home
who's the best whoever gets the final
blow thank you
hunter warlock or titan there you go
that's the truth
okay here we
pressure
go
pressure
no pressure check whoever gets the final
blow i'm gonna jump real high in the sky
and then you know you want a lifetime
supply
kind of
oh he has to leave oh crap okay that's
cool
dude i i i let's go here we have okay so
this is bombastic yeah you're on the
bridge yeah
you like that i like it i looked that
one up last night
[Music]
[Laughter]
i said i'm gonna use it once at least
a total total pivot from the
conversation apologize i just can't stop
thinking about it
right are you ready are you
world's first thing going for world's
first for kingston yeah yeah i'm i'm
going for world's first second
world's 100 we're yeah world's second
week going i'm going for fun
that's why we like it if we win we win
i'm actually really excited because
king's fall is the one raid from destiny
1 i never got to play really and i
refused all play testing i refused to
see it early i was like i want to go in
completely blind
so i've heard that there's some jumping
oh god what happened victory wow
oh that looks brilliant gonna get back
up oh we got you guys
we know it's good when everybody goes
hype moments all right got another super
let's go okay we got to take so we got a
nice tether conservators
nice tether that's keeping the boss safe
love to see that your health's getting
kind of low you can do this you're fine
all right
he's a titan baby he's good
oh dude i just want to see if i can get
in his head a little bit
don't let him win
don't let him win
hey andy is your like game crashing or
like you think you need to step away for
a
destroying second much stuff that might
seem that way but you know i don't know
when you do as much as the hunters do
you know just jump around
first of all blink around okay you blink
around now we got a second of all yes
at your crewmates they will emote back
at you and celebrate
yeah that's an in-game feature i love it
i love it i just love these guys digging
for treasure on the left over here
[Laughter]
they don't care about everything else
going on around them they're just like
we got to get this trailer
they're happy to be here for sure i just
want the gold i think if i ever found
gold like that i don't even think i
would steal it i would just roll around
in it like darling dunk like the uh
yeah they're quick ducks like the the
duck that shall not be named mcdonald's
dark wing duck gets dangerous it's not
too ship [ __ ] it's dangerous i don't
know i'm old
it's scrooge
is it scrooge yeah
it's been a while see this is why i
don't make cartoons all right so we got
one more catch crash
and then you know as much as i love
hanging out with you yeah we got to do
this catch crash
uh i want to get my hands on the game
all right so let's load it up one more
time and show the people at home how
it's done
hunters
oh where where's the lights
i'll go for you warlock's got it
warlocks continue to look fashionable
yeah i'm like you guys representation
[Laughter]
this is why nobody likes warlocks ellie
because of that
i'll take a warlock on my team
in all fairness i'll take them all you
know i'll be the fashionable one doing
all the dps and all the hard mechanics
and everything else but you know
we need the bubble and we need the will
we do need so i do i do like i i am that
toxic player in trials that uh pops
bubble right at the last second so you
think you have hope
that's just called the winning strategy
all right that's just normal i'm not
familiar with winning strategies though
you've played trials with me you know
that's about me i'm not ashamed i'm not
proud and you just go forward
[Music]
what is this dude
show these weapons off i got yeah i got
to see i got to see what everybody got i
got to see whatever we got what do you
got
[Music]
that looks like a like a rocket launcher
too this is awesome okay we're showing
off some new ways you've got a good roll
too this is great
he's like pretty difficult he's like i
know i'm naturally awesome thank you for
noticing thanks for finally getting with
the
i got the program
oh so i want to see how that does
yeah i want to see how that would be you
check out the smg i want to check out
this slug shotgun
dude i'm not going to lie
incandescent made me love shotguns
it's such a good perk and so like now
i'm excited to actually because i never
gave shotguns a chance until that just
give me incandescent on everything yes
just make me incandescent i'm fine with
it i'll just blow up everybody around me
it's cool
we might just be a curse
it's totally normal everything's fine
don't worry about it we're good
we're not gucci but we're like
salvation army closed on a sunday
it's fine so nick's got a new weapon
yeah they i mean everybody got like
something oh this different oh it looks
so what's the rpm on this bad boy tell
us about this smg it feels like it's
like a kind of rpm uh which is pretty
good
can we get three seconds
no no
you never will i'm i'm the lord guy i'm
not the weapons guy feels real good to
click
it seems to kill people if you shoot it
enough times it does its job there you
go
it's fun oh man and then
what i'm excited is sniper the sniper
mod we got with the news
i'm just like i'm like planning my
business i'm so jealous everybody gets
to play and i'm already like smoking out
my builds
so will's got a new weapon what do you
got will i've got a new uh scout rifle
that feels really good has four times
fourth time the charm and explosive
payload um but the feel of it just it
feels right
i love it
i'm a feels kind of guy exactly there's
certain there's certain weapons where
you know you shoot it once and you're
like and uh it's not for me but this you
know right away that you like this one i
i like it i like it
i just i'm so proud
i'm just so proud of the teams i know
i'm not supposed to do that
we're doing we're doing the casual
gameplay thing but i just i am i'm
thinking of all the people that make
this come together there's so many i
think a lot of players don't understand
how many teams are involved in things
like this it's not one person it's not
one team
and if one t you know you have to have
that cohesion that alignment if you
don't it feels weird
and they have like all of the
environmentals the weapons how they feel
how they look how they sound how they
interact with others
it's just it's it's magical it's crazy
and you got to meet a lot of the people
that see it seeing how it all works
behind the scenes is incredible like ray
here has a new heavy weapon what do you
got ray i'm sure this is magical as well
yeah
new linear fusion rifle feels pretty
good out loud
that was a good grenade though
outlaw frenzy that was good
that was amazing it sounds like a spicy
roll feel like you need an arc buddy
though
do you do the sound effects like nick
does
not he comes at the right time okay
he can't rush perfection what would the
sound effect for this linear be no he he
was equipped with dignity
[Laughter]
there you go
oh my god hey at least we don't have a
weapon this time that shoots an animal
like worms
like a sassy worm that likes to sass you
and you judge you for all of your life
choices you didn't like that you mean i
liked it i just felt very inadequate
after
[Laughter]
maybe i just have a problem with
authority i don't know we'll explore
that later that's a therapist dog
oh this chain lighting is so good i was
about to say i just saw a bunch of stuff
just light up i think that's my favorite
thing about arc is you can see the
reaction damage yes and you don't always
get that with every subclass if it
doesn't line up perfectly so when you
see like that visualization
you just feel awesome
like you feel epic like you feel like
nobody can touch you and then you die
two seconds later because then you were
talking about how great you were all
right so ray looks like you got what do
you have a ball here ball here
oh someone took it
i'm sorry it's mine
we love balls
wow
would you say you're pondering the orbs
or perpetually perpetually pondering
orbs perpetually
perpendicular
the dead man's tail i got no composure
as well just because i'm using rifle
yeah i also got a linear one as well
okay this is the new linear same rule
and everything uh i don't think it's the
same rule i think it's it's an okay role
it's sideways and focus here sideways
focus okay and i'm doing a lot of
sliding around since i got uh liar's
handshake on i'm just doing anything i
can to close the gap some sustained boss
dps for focus fury wherever i can you
gotta do social proud man quick sliding
reloads perfect for hunter yeah
those little is that oh that's the slide
okay the slide's all in the hip you got
to lead oh not the true yeah an
appropriate action i'm doing now okay so
yeah no that's maybe that's why i'm not
a hunter because i just try to do this
or maybe you would just be a great
hunter and we're terrified of your
skills
terrified of greatness absolutely
i'm terrified of being too great we're
just going to be battling over with the
subclass okay come on man
i know i just talked to warlocks but
uh i just so you guys know like i love
you guys y'all are having fun i'm really
happy for you great wonderful
but i am kicking you out after this one
because like i i
i gotta play i i can't i'm like super
impatient i gotta play
love you guys you're pretty i cherish
you
you gotta go home we got to go we got to
go
you don't have to go home
yeah can't stay here we're almost done
we're almost to that end we got to get
that loot first
we got to get that loop first
there's a button up here
oh whoa thank you
that was cool
lots of lightning
all exploding incoming
oh hey can i hit you oh thank you okay
oh the turtle
thought you were rocking dmt for a
second please oh i was like of course
yeah i'm back
that just looks so powerful
i'm excited for strand though too with
lightfall like every time it was funny
because anybody time anybody would ask
me like give me a spoiler give me a hint
of what's coming and i would just be
like it's you and me spiderman
[Laughter]
and nobody knew what i was talking about
and the second they saw the grapple
they're like
[Music]
okay i get it now stupid but we get it
there's at least a reason behind the
joke
it's fine that's awesome oh yeah you
guys got this in the bag
so are we at the front looks like we are
at the final ball too yeah we're coming
on to it
lots of fallen
spinny swords as we're kind of wrapping
this up last minute thoughts what you
guys think you have fun
did you
not put your best foot forward
[Laughter]
the only thing
did you not
i have a work ordained reason to play
video games during the day
i'm doing good yeah i love it i love it
i'm just excited for my my main warlock
class be back
oh this is great so don't stop
keep heading to the bridge keep heading
to bridge we're going to go ahead and
start wrapping up because i want to play
absolutely fire team yes yes after this
yes
let's do it i love it i love it i love
it i love it come on dee
all right we're gonna we're gonna close
this out keep heading to the bridge
as much as i wanna keep you here forever
because you're a gem and we love you
we can't
we saw a lot of things today
we saw ark we saw lightfall
we saw joe's mustache
we saw a lot of beautiful things and
we're really excited i thank you guys so
much for tuning in with us we know that
we have
a lot we threw a lot at you today we
threw fortnight we threw fall guys we
threw everything
really excited my auntie and uncle
showed up wait auntie and uncle decided
to crash the party so before we do all
that we're going to
tell people where they can find you
because you're awesome and you're a gym
and i want people to know where you are
well my name is d flawless and you can
find me pretty much everywhere uh
streaming live twitch.tv slash d
underscore flawless restream pretty much
every weekday
and we also post funny videos on the
internet tik tok twitter at the d
flawless go check them out and just
thank you guys everyone here thank you
so much for having me out this has been
amazing seeing all the new things seeing
all the people like uh
my heart is full it our heart is full
too man it was a pleasure we got to have
you back you
you killed it you crushed it anytime
anytime i can't wait to go into this new
adventure with you we're gonna
be okay pirate we're gonna be the
world's okayest pirates i like that i
like it before you guys join in remember
that season 18 of susan of the plunder
is live
now so like you should totally go play
it but first before you go we have a
couple things remember new and returning
players we have the gift of the thunder
gods which is going to make sure that
you can jump into the action with no
issues and some pretty swanky new gear
and on top of that we also have all of
the expansions free for a limited time
so make sure you cash in on that make
sure you get your twitch drops make sure
you got your entries in for giveaways
and before we kick it off you know we
had a lot of love in chat you guys have
absolutely just been the most amazing
community ever we want to spread that
love a little bit so we're gonna go
ahead and introduce you to another
amazing content creator she goes by pika
and i need you guys to really bring the
noise in her chat tell her we said hello
tell her we love her
tell her she's doing awesome with art
because i know she is
and uh
yeah really honestly what are you still
doing here yeah go go play season go say
hi to pika go have fun
[Music]
you